this is jocko podcast number 328 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield
it's the most important thing in
business and it is the most important
thing in life
and on this podcast we
consistently and regularly
go through
examples of that
from military history
and about how the principles of extreme
ownership apply to combat situations and
i've had
many
combat leaders
on this podcast from every level from
corporals and sergeants
to gun resurgence and master chiefs to
generals and admirals
talking about
these principles of leadership and how
they apply on the battlefield and
sometimes they talk about how these
principles positively impact their lives
if well as well so we've covered the
battlefield we've covered life
tonight we're going to get a perspective
from the business side from an
individual
that has taken the principles of extreme
ownership the laws of combat the
leadership strategy and tactics that we
learned in combat
and has applied them directly to his
business resulting in some
incredible
success
our guest tonight is matt malone
he's the ceo and owner of groundworks
which is a
nationwide
construction company that
provides foundation repair basement
waterproofing crawl space encapsulation
and concrete lifting
and a host of other services that helps
keep americans foundations dry and safe
and serviceable it's a company that's
ranked
number 1047 on the inc 5000 in 2021 grew
by 461 percent in three years
has over 20 brands under its umbrella
still growing
and that growth is based on leadership
and that leadership starts with the ceo
matt
thanks for coming on thank you jaco an
honor to be here let's uh let's start at
the beginning let's start at where you
started yes sir tell us about uh growing
up
well i grew up in uh a town not too
dissimilar to to this one not as pretty
uh norfolk virginia come on man come on
man norfolk's pretty pretty pretty place
i looked out the window at the last
night or
this morning
overlooking the little harbor there it's
like man
i see the big navy vessels but doesn't
quite look the same as my hometown but
uh a lot of similarities a lot of
similarities a lot of differences but so
i grew up in norfolk uh norfolk virginia
for those that don't know it's uh
you know it's probably east coast
command for the seals it's the world's
largest navy base i think uh a lot of
ship building there as well
um i'm a navy brat so my my dad
was enlisted in the navy's uh
he made us with there had made his way
there from texas so he was born in
denison texas a classic story that you
probably see a lot
tough childhood
um
he said i'm gonna go join the navy and
see the world and uh he did he did
he was enlisted e5
but he spent four years in the navy two
years in the guard but it brought him to
norfolk as you can imagine there he met
my mom and uh she too was a navy brat so
my grandfather
he uh he was a chief warrant officer so
he's uh 20 years plus so he he served he
was actually
in the pacific theater for the most of
his career
yeah um
he was uh injured and
uh kamikaze attack and you know he's got
some great stories
he was on well i only know in in the
atlantic he was on his first ship was
the brooklyn the uss brooklyn
um he's no longer with us so in fact i
i was trying to find some things before
i came to see you to see if i could get
some more data but uh
i do he was
he lived um and kind of raised for many
years my mom in guam so you know he was
pacific theater and
um
you know finally moved back to retire in
norfolk and and that's how you know my
parents met so it's you know
navy towns are a lot of examples like
that yeah so what'd your dad do while
you're growing up
you know it's funny in the navy so he's
the texas guy tough life um ran away
frankly to to get some freedom um in the
navy he he was involved with computers
of all things which back in the day that
was know i think
there was that like a calculator it was
like he would have these big
tape type things that he would chug
around and
um that was the skill that he learned in
the navy and then he went to work for
as this kind of new technology rolled
out in the banking world so he would
oversee the computers at a couple local
regional banks now when i was a kid
i went on a field trip so this is we're
talking this might be 1977 or something
like that i was young
and i remember we went to a bank on a
field trip
and first of all i was just thinking
this is the most boring thing i've ever
seen in my life i don't want to i'm
never going in a bank but they had this
thing that they were calling a computer
and they had the little these little
punch cards and i think it was some kind
of an ibm computer system that kept
track of something and i remember
thinking well
not going into banking over here i'm
sure there's some kids that
were thinking wow look at that guy with
a briefcase remember do you think a
briefcase was ever cool echo charles
no not that i can yeah i remember some
kids thought a briefcase was cool
i wasn't one of those kids so so think
going into a big room now with stacks
and stacks of machinery and they had to
take these tapes down every night and
move them for security to a different
location it wasn't like
you talked computers today it's coding
and all these you know kind of glamorous
things it was the opposite of that so he
would
manage a store as the tapes would store
the data from the transaction i guess
from the customers during the day and
make sure they're protected really
didn't know what he did but i too knew
that
i never wanted to do that
but you know as a kid you just uh
uh it's uh i would just say that my
parents uh uh just great people
we grew up as you can imagine fairly
poor so we
lived in a 1200 square foot house with
one bathroom i have a brother um but
never knew it frankly never knew
what wealth really was just knew that my
parents loved me and just got after my
mom was a telephone operator
when
eckerd didn't know what that is but they
don't have this anymore i'm laughing
because that statement about like
we didn't have much money but you know
we didn't really know it
so both my parents were school teachers
we didn't have much money and i knew it
i was we were we i remember we had like
a car we had one car for a while we had
one car it was a chevette
scooter a beige chevette scooter with no
air conditioning
and that had like a crappy am radio
and and we would get get into that thing
in the summer time to go like drive to
see the grandparents three kids in the
back of the tiniest car
so when people are like oh you know i
was poor but we didn't know it
i knew it
i knew it man i was like i'm getting out
of this joint when i can't i'm having
flashbacks so we we we had a similar we
had a rabbit remember these volkswagen
rabbits
two-door not four-door and so my dad was
from texas occasionally we'd make the
long drive from virginia to texas no ac
oh my god oh we have pictures of the
four of us in this thing and um yeah you
know it was good times yeah and of
course i mean uh i don't want to make it
sound too bad
when you have a car you're not doing too
bad right and and we've always had food
so
thanks to my mom and dad and and the the
teachers union that they got paid
and we ate we got to eat all the time
but yeah uh as far as not knowing you're
poor i definitely i let me rephrase that
i knew we didn't have much money that
much i do i knew we weren't i knew we
weren't getting
like you know a new bicycle we might get
a used bicycle we might get a you know
um
we always had some fun around christmas
time uh the the saying in my family was
it's gonna be a lean christmas yeah
which had been inherited i guess for my
my mom's dad who would say the same
thing it's gonna be a lean christmas so
that's all we'd hear about
so whatever dreams you had for santa
go count on it yeah
well look echo would appreciate this
being from hawaii look um the big meal
sometimes during the week was spam
now back east that wasn't a thing my mom
grew up in guam for many years right so
yeah we'll fire up some spam and put in
a crock pot and then
like what
so the running joke when i realized that
spam really wasn't real me to see my mom
she made she signed me up for the spam
of the month club and i had a sweet
shirt that said spam on and i would get
this letter every month
so you know again
it took me a while to realize hey you
guys don't need spam at your house you
know so anyway
but so grew up in norfolk um you know uh
good parents normal childhood
um i i actually going to elementary
school i went uh this was when crosstown
busing was a thing i don't know if they
have that here in california but back in
the day the
we would have crosstown bussing in
norfolk so i grew up in a place called
ocean view
um i don't know if you remember that i
don't know if you were stationed back in
the i was stationed i remember where
ocean view is it's a little sketchy
we'll talk about that later maybe but uh
so a crosstown busing was a big deal so
in first grade you know mom would walk
me out to the bus stop 45 50 minute
drive on the bus
to a school
um young park elementary it's literally
in the middle of a project and it did
you know they would cross down bus and
so that lasted for a couple years and
mom had enough of it so she said hey
we're going to find the money to send
of course every brother parish and
and we're going to send the boys to a
catholic school because catholic schools
are uh cheaper than private schools uh
but great education is good educations
and so we ended up going to this little
private school um and she was so pleased
i think i think it was like two thousand
dollars but you know but for those real
money right and so
um now it kind of changed the course of
my my life and and uh fast forward a few
years so we grew up and
grew up there and then went to high
school when you say that it changed the
course of your life
you can't just throw that out there and
then just say hey we're moving on well
what just the the focus on education
yeah so the focus on
look discipline i think is an important
part of aspect of a catholic uh
education now you know i literally had
nuns that were teaching us right so you
have some discipline that's instilled in
that some you know again we're not
catholic either right so did you did you
have to tell say that you're catholic to
get in no no no okay they they allow
non-catholics to get in okay and so
but you know i i certainly believe in
the morality that they they teach
and i would literally have to go to we
went to mass every week and i couldn't
participate right so literally for me it
was like uh
reception i just go and sit and i always
remember it's nice and cool in the
church were they still doing the in
latin no no no not at this point no not
at this point how long ago is latin
services
am i
am i crazy no because they used to talk
about that like i thought they did latin
up until fairly recently you know the
70s or 60s uh
long before maybe maybe i was i'm not
that old maybe i'm not i don't know they
definitely did in latin but uh but not
for me not for me but i just remember
you know we couldn't participate
couldn't take the sacrament and um but
it was cool i would go as nice and cool
in there and just sit and do whatever
and there were a few non-catholics so we
just kind of pal around together we were
that group
um and just would just chill as people
would go
through the mass every week and that's
cool whatever but um
how it changed my life is you know a
good curriculum
a good focus on discipline and education
and and candidly a good moral compass
was delivered uh weekly right now i'm
not talking about maths here i'm just
talking about you know how they went
about their education right look if you
look at today
is a there's a boom in catholic
education uh given what's going on in
education around the country and so
um you know it was an important part of
my kind of upbringing even though i
wasn't catholic it was it was important
part of my upbringing and how long were
you in that catholic school for well i
went so second grade so third grade on
through high school oh all the way
through high school yeah so um different
schools but still in the catholic system
so all these little teeny catholic
elementary schools would feed up to the
one
high school they had in town at this
time it was called norfolk catholic high
and uh so my brother and i went there
and uh so my my dad passed away when i
was 14 so i was a freshman it was tough
uh how'd that happen
well he so he he again grew up in texas
without a lot of medical care and uh
what they think was so see he had
rheumatic fever when he was a child and
um you know likely he never got medical
attention until it was probably too late
so he literally wore glasses because the
the fever burned his his retinas right
so i mean remember so he was born in the
late 50s
and you know in texas not in a big city
he was he was born in denison texas and
literally lived on a cattle farm right
so different mindset about health care
and and and and treating things
aggressively so oh he's got 103
temperature he'll be all right just you
know just lay down here's some water you
know we'll be fine but he he ultimately
wasn't fine so he had
he had uh kidney failure um a couple
years prior so he was on dialysis for
that and
you know he would he would uh literally
go on walks every morning to kind of
keep in shape and he was thin
built uh not built like me he was thin
and we go on these walks and um
one day he just didn't come back uh
police come to the house and we're about
to go to school my brother and i and
um my brother he was a couple years
older and he would drive us to school
and the cops literally came into we
lived in a court came to the drove
through the court
and i remember we're just kind of
sitting there
i was getting a drink of water from the
faucet and uh i made some smart ass
comment like oh they're coming to get
this guy roger baker over here you know
uh again you know
rough neighborhood candidly so a lot of
guys the police would come by all the
time
and so he pulled right in front of the
house and i said something outsmart to
my brother like oh what'd you do
and so he comes to the door and he
brings my dad's wallet and uh he said
one of you guys needs to come with me
and so my brother was the oldest and so
he went
um he went with the police officer and
you know i was there alone in that house
and um that's just a very strange i mean
when your child was 14 just turned 14
just entering in high school as a
freshman
and uh yeah and i called my mom and
she came home and you know went to the
hospital and he was gone so
um at an early age you know when that
that
that happens you you
you have one or two things right you
have to you can either hide within
yourself or you can stop and try to be
more of a man around the house and and
my mom
um you know she she's old school in the
sense that you know she was very
dependent on my dad um
she turned into we called her tawanda
after that like she's tried to be strong
and do things that uh
you know that
she needed to do take care of her boys
and she did
but i had to become
in my mind i had to become more the man
of the house and and manage the finances
and other things like that because she
wasn't great with that and so
um the interesting thing is she couldn't
afford to send us to this school now
norfolk catholic and
and i didn't know this for a few years
but the school came to her and said hey
listen if you can pay for
one
of your son's child uh my brother um
then matt can go for free
big deal right so um
that's how i was able to go to high
school is that that school stepped up
and allowed
you know two knuckleheads to go to
school and when when i couldn't really
afford it my mom couldn't afford it
and i found out you know many years
later but uh my wife sarah and i have
you know we've given a lot of money back
to the school and uh we've endowed a few
scholarships for athletes to go to
school it's just
more than you know the colleges i went
to that was
you know kind of the greatest act of
kindness that set me on a course to to
be an entrepreneur and a businessman
today and uh so i just i love that place
um and sarah and i continue to get back
to it but
so that
high school um you know aside from that
pretty pretty
typical existence i played sports not
great like you guys
i played football and basketball
marginal at football
you know all conference i think i made
all-state one time but uh not great i
remember
like uh junior year
um it's about you getting ready to go to
college and look to be fair i was
complete knucklehead uh might had a 2.2
gpa so your grades were not great no
grades are not great were you just not
studying no just didn't care i don't
really think i brought a book home and
and um
you know i
and i have i factually did not think
about home
well i mean you have you have kids and
some sons so i literally i i have two
sons now and
i would be appalled if that were the
case for my son so
um
and looking back like what a nugget so
my mom worked all the time she you know
i was a latke kid i literally
i saw her you know right before bed and
that was it because she had to work and
so
um i remember going to a guidance
counselor back in the day and the
guidance counselor literally said hey
you might want to think about a career
in the shipyards
and i'm like what do you mean
you know mom says i need to go to
college
she's like yeah but
mom hasn't seen your dreams
you're not getting into college the lady
said um and you know norfolk is a home a
bunch of shipyards right and so
um and nothing wrong with working in the
shipyards and i'll cover that in a
little bit but she
she was like you need to go or think
about that as a profession right so i'd
go home
that was not a good conversation with
mom
she never went to college of course but
she'd already she knew about this thing
called college she said my boys are
going to college i don't know what that
looks like but my boys are going to
college and so
thankfully i could play football now
i should i should say that you know
lightly i could play football was smart
enough to kind of talk my way and play
my way into college but d3 so d3
you know
echo played you know d once who's legit
but d3
i joke around it's like 13th grade
so and they also don't give any money to
go to play d3 but they they allow
at least for me they allowed a
knucklehead into school so i was able to
parlay kind of my average football skill
into and i'm a decent-sized guy but i
could i could leverage that into getting
into college and so i did so
um
this is this is the
interesting too so
i went to which college to go to so i
initially went to you know catholic
university so mind you
here's a guy i'm episcopalian like and
so imagine a all my career has been
educational
milking the system
um
you know
so
so i ended up at catholic university
which is a division three school but
it's in dc and uh
um so i played football there but
quickly boom blow out my knee
yeah right and i remember
i'm not going to that shipyard
i can't go back right so um
so my mind had to turn on turn the brain
on i remember what year was this in
college that you blew your knee so i
graduated high school in 90s 91
91 and uh so did you play a season or
did you no never saw the field
how did you blow your knee practicing
yeah okay yeah
and look i had a couple looks from
service academies and of course that was
never going to happen given my grades
but um
but it was the only way i could really
get an opportunity to go to college and
and so
i went to catholic um blew out my knee
but because of my fear i decided okay
there's this thing called a brain you
might want to turn that on
i
you're looking back
you're looking back and you say oh this
is what i said do you
actually remember a moment in time when
you said okay i'm gonna need to i'm
gonna need to apply myself academically
100 okay so you that that actually
because i look at my people i was like
hey when did this happen when was this
moment and i i've always for the most
part had more gradual
sort of
realizations of what's happening in the
world including for myself but that's
why i'm asking they're like did you have
a specific like all right
literally
it's a binary event right so you blow
out your knee you can't walk i was
literally in the hospital like southeast
dc not the greatest kind of hospital
that you want to be in and i literally
in that bed i said i'm not going back
not i'm not meeting catholic but i'm not
going back to norfolk
i'm not going to go back
what i got to do right so um turned on
the brain i finished the semester there
had a 3-2 which is okay
um
i didn't frankly fit i didn't like the
place um i didn't like i didn't like
living in dc and so
um
again my mom she she does she did we
couldn't really afford college right so
she did a lot of research and she found
that there's a a foundation in norfolk
called the norfolk foundation
and they literally
for underprivileged kids they would send
these kids to this this this college
ultimate graduate from called hampton
sydney college is in virginia it's a
classic liberal arts school so when i
say classic
you know they talk greek and latin we
had two years of something called
rhetoric and you had to place out of it
before you could graduate right it is so
old school it's like a true academy and
i loved it right so it was small less
than a thousand
students
professor to student ratio was very high
and professors that taught there they
wanted to teach they didn't want to
write the research they wanted to teach
and it was a perfect environment for me
and so
i went there
the norfolk foundation
paid my tuition
what'd you study uh economics and
religion believe it or not so i have two
degrees from there one in economics and
one in religion
people always ask me what
that religion thing is late once you
know me you realize that religion thing
malone what what do you have that for
well it's just
look economics was pure i wanted to to
learn more about you know the economy
and how to be effective in business and
things like that but
my curiosity was really what drove
religion right so imagine going to
school at a catholic school for all my
my childhood
and then of course i'm episcopalian but
i was just fascinated with the idea
of
how religions are historically rolled
out and maintained and their effect
their effect on you know mankind and so
we would study all kinds of religions
and so it's just it was a personal kind
of journey of my own intellect not
frankly not doing anything with this as
you can imagine yeah we'll know if i was
in the fbi and saw that thing pop up i
would have pegged you as a cult
potential future cult leader economy and
religion right we gotta watch this guy
he's gonna be making moves well look the
iron so i wrote my senior thesis on
something called the morality of
capitalism um so i tried to blend them
together that uh did so did you know you
wanted to go into business
at this time were you starting to think
did you see some kind of a career path
was there anything that interested you
you know
i knew i didn't want to go into a
traditional profession when i say
professional i mean true profession so
you know law or medicine or accounting
like i
my mind wasn't linear that way and and i
always knew that i wanted to pursue
something in business whatever that
might mean like it's so
it's so ambiguous when you say hey yeah
i want to go into business well what
what the heck does that even mean right
what does that look like and
and um i just knew i wanted to to have
the tools to do that jockey to go into
business and be successful it was later
that i learned kind of what specifically
i wanted to be involved with in business
as i met some some mentors but
uh at hampton sydney you know i just
knew i wanted to get some degree and and
uh that i felt like could best prepare
me to be successful in business and
so i did my as i said i got this norfolk
foundation scholarship right so
and i get there my
my dad's gone no one in my family has
ever gone to college um
mom thought this was and i thought okay
look this is cool i got this all paid
for right well i get there and what i
realized they pay tuition but there's a
little difference between room and board
and things like that so
i i'm a hustler so i've always worked
even as in high school like it's just
part of the malone mindset we've always
worked i remember i was working at a
marina at 14
sanding the bottom of boats so they
could
paint them now mind you i didn't even
have any kind of
face mask on like today with my company
like
what were they what were they letting me
do that for
because you know 14 right
i better not say the marina but i was
paid in cash and my brother worked there
and he got the good gig so he drove one
of these huge forklifts uh where they
stored the boats and you know they're
huge forklift and
i was the idiot that would climb up on
the forklift get in the boat as he put
it in the water so i could drive it and
park it so when the guests came they
could pick up their boats anyway so we'd
always been working and um
even in high school i think you
appreciate this and you might know these
guys so i was a lifeguard of all things
in high school believe it or not so i
worked at this uh ocean view
uh life beach patrol
and uh a good gig paid a lot more than
marina didn't have to work as hard you
can kind of work out have some fun
you're not breathing lead paint
right down your throat as i look at it
um
uh now you know people always joke hey
were you there for the ladies and stuff
like i don't think you've really been to
ocean view bro there's really no ladies
there
um
it's a pretty rough place like
we used to work at this place called
there are a couple beaches there in
norfolk and we worked at this place
called city beach
and city there's a big development now
it's replaced it but city was kind of
way down at the end of the end of the
bay
and there were that's where you could
get the hotels you could get for the
hour right and hookers on the corners
and stuff like that and they only let
the big guys go down there to city and
we called it of course shitty we're
gonna go hit shitty
what i love those we had rescue boards
and so we basically served all day
because the clientele didn't roll and
mind you surfing out in norfolk is very
different than here but
but we felt cool jocko come on so
you know okay well you know you get
there you get on duty at 10
and clients don't really show up at that
beach until about three so we kind of
screwed around
well
there's a couple characters that you
meet during being a lifeguard right so
you have the quintessential guy that
that's his profession you know the dude
that's like you would call him dude his
name was jed
like he was 40 years old you're like
okay i don't want to be that guy but we
had these a few guys that went to uh
that went to college at old dominion and
that were just working there for the
summer making good money and and uh
i never forget this one guy
um he was a workout maniac so he was a
wrestler at old dominion and we our
lifeguard stands are about 10 feet tall
and uh
he used to hang off these things and do
pull-ups
and then he would do one-handed pull-ups
you know he'd grab his hands and
complete legit
and i was in high school this this this
was cool to me right so on his hey i'm
not a i'm i'm way out of high school
my fat ass can't do that that's pretty
cool so
on the lunch breaks though this guy
he wouldn't go on lunch he would
literally jump on the beach take off his
lifeguard gear and dig holes he'd take
out a military shovel and dig holes
as deep as he could as fast as he could
for an hour and then fill him and that's
not a lunch break was an hour
and uh
and i remember asking him he said
what do you what do you mean i love it
but what are you doing
he says i want to be a seal
i said huh
what's a seal right and so
at city beach it's right across a jetty
from um i think
am fed base there right and so you'd see
copters out there dropping people and i
didn't think there were seals but you
just did drop you know divers in or
whatever
and because i was so busy down there at
that beach i could just sit there with
my bikes and watch
you see them swimming back right they
just swim back and say man these guys
are out there a long time
and he would say well those are probably
seals and then he came in one day and
gave me a book
rogue warrior
the classic right so of course there's a
lot of reading time sometimes on these
lifeguard stands because no one was
there so marcinka i read that book and
and uh
and it was fun the other day i was
working out with um
retired seal
and i and i had this
i stole i shouldn't say that but i have
a a a lifeguard sign in my gym at home
my garage
i found that
city of norfolk i found that but um so
we're working on he says hey what's that
sign and i said i worked i worked at the
i worked this on this lifeguard thing
and
then i remembered the story of this guy
that wanted to be a seal and i said hey
did did you ever know this guy he and
his face he looked at me and said
you're kidding right so
uh so his name and i i have i've been
seeing him since jocko so you should
know this so his
they had two guys that worked there
they're called the fossil brothers
john and chris fussell worked
as lifeguards with me back in the day
at ocean view john fussell was the guy
that would just
work workout maniac like hanging off
lifeguard sands digging holes and
you know when i when i mentioned that
deflana do you know this guy's like are
you kidding right
so i did use interwebs and check them
out so i i guess they made it and they
had a pretty good career in the seal
team so
um but i literally remember this guy
hanging off the lifeguard stand doing
you know one on purl-ups which uh so he
made it good for them so yeah
small story there but
you know always working um
so when i get to college of course
realizing i had to figure out how to eat
and where to live and things like that
so i got a couple jobs
one one of those jobs was i was a
bartender now so i went to this school
is in the middle of the mountains of
virginia so not much
nightlife but i worked for the school so
i would
work for these trustee events
so trustees in college are folks that
you know kind of sit on a board and give
a lot of money and kind of direct the
college and where it's going so they're
pretty typically pretty successful folks
that can afford to give a lot of money
away and
you know i hadn't exposed to any of that
world before and so i was working these
trustee events and you know had to wear
bow tie and it's pretty horrible
so i stand there and have the this bar
and that this this this gentleman
freshman year came up and
um he wanted to scotch and eat
really good at making those
uh
so
and so we just got talking for four
years we talked and again not about
business but about life and politics and
sports and
um you know he he really became someone
that i look forward to talking to and
um his name was bob hatcher
and
and bob had started a company
um
that um
called johnson higgins which was one of
the largest insurance brokerage firms in
the world he later sold to marsh and
they are the largest and and you know i
don't know what he was worth but it was
a lot and i remember senior year he says
uh hey malone if you ever
if you ever need anything give me a call
and
you know
okay what does that mean right so again
naive i said yes sir mr hatcher thank
you you know
so anyway so uh graduate hampton sydney
the brain turned on believe it or not
phi beta kappa which all these you know
pretty high gpa um
which is what it taught me was like you
focus on anything you bring some
discipline to your studies
most people can achieve anything right
especially in school it's it's not that
hard you just got to be disciplined
about it and i took it as my job like i
was there
to find a path to get out get the
highest gpa i could to get theoretically
give me the best job that i could
so as i'm finishing up school
one of the deans of the schools comes to
me and says hey malone i want you to
apply for this scholarship
and of course i heard scholarships so
free and i said okay what's this about
and he he encouraged me to apply for
something called the rotary foundation
scholarship
actually the road the rotary
ambassadorial fellowship
very fancy
and through the rotary club well
apparently i have rotary clubs
throughout the world
and um
part of this this this ambassadorial
role is that you go to these countries
one wherever country you're designated
and you speak to rotary clubs in that
country uh every weekend so you travel
around those countries giving speeches
about literally life in america where
you're from it's truly ambassadorial
and in return for that they pay for your
your graduate school it's like that's a
good gig
i'll give that a go and so
um now i can only speak english and so
you know there's only that limits to
where you can go in the world i said
australia or the united kingdom right so
um i um being an economist leaves that
phrase loosely i knew um of course of
you know adam smith
he he actually taught at the university
of glasgow in scotland there's a school
there called adam smith school of
finance
and i applied to fund the way it worked
is you have to apply and then they the
rotary club picks
and so of course i pick the big boys i
applied to cambridge and lunch school of
economics use the big boys right
and on the fifth choice i i applied to
university of glasgow now what's
interesting about glasgow it's very
similar to norfolk
um in the sense a huge ship building
town depressed economies
um
because most of the ships at the back in
at least
early on a lot of the shipyards for the
united kingdom all the boats were really
built right there and uh in glasgow
and so of course that's where they
select me to go and so i ended and
i wish i'd gone to cambridge or oxford
or one of these places so i of course
end up my luck going to university of
glasgow but hey man it was free
um so i went so off i go to uh
university of glasgow in scotland and
and uh
yeah that that was a good experience i
the school was like 1491 it was found i
mean so it's it's you going way back
right and uh definitely back in the day
my classmates who love this one my
classmates were really it's an
international program so my classmates
from around the world right so
my my roommate was a fellow named carl
howe who's from barbados and uh
you know he he spoke a different dialect
of english um and then i don't know if
you've been to glasgow but glaswegian
obviously english but their accent are
so thick so imagine i'm i got this dude
from barbados
me
and all these glaswegians it's like it's
it's they're all speaking the same
language but they're amazing
so
i did uh i did the masters program there
in international finance
i really wanted to get out of there so i
did my program pretty fast i did it then
18 months
you could write your dissertation finish
and so i finished
um but because i finished early i i came
back to the states and and at that point
jack i i i wanted to be i thought an
investment banker so
for your listeners out there not defend
many investment bankers but so
investment bankers put
buyers and sellers of companies together
um
i have a lot of investment banking
friends who apologize for this but
they're like real estate agents
but really smart and they make a ton of
dough
so in my mind i wanted to be an
investment banker you know kind of
facilitating
um acquisitions and putting buyers and
sellers to together for for for
businesses and so
going back to the states i was off cycle
so they have a recruiting class so they
they bring in students and put them in
the associated program after they get
their mba which my degree was equivalent
to that
and so i was kind of six seven months
early for that program
and um they said hey just come back when
we recruit for the program because it's
kind of a couple year program you got to
get get a spot a slot and you'll go
through the program
and so i called bob because i didn't
have a job and i said hey mr hatcher
guess who and he says hey milan
so i wrote this dissertation on
derivatives in graduate school and so i
went to work briefly
for this insurance company and i
i literally wrote what's called
exogenous risk models where i would
invertly correlate commodity prices
uh and self-insurance levels it's very
technical very boring but we've both
seen trading places so we kind of there
you go
right
so uh i literally would build these
models you got here that i literally was
building these models um
that so a lot of big companies are
self-insured
some companies have massive exposure to
their earnings based on a commodity
price of something so like take reynolds
models for example so reynolds metals
their earnings are probably driven by
the commodity price of aluminum
well if you're self-insured to some
level
and aluminum prices go through the roof
you had taken more and more risk
so we kind of wrote these and developed
these models derivative products that as
the commodity price of
in this case aluminum would go up
your insurance would kick in so your
self-insurance would go down so it
allowed the company to have less risk
yeah i i realize in about a month this
is really cool but it ain't for me i'm
not sitting no cube doing modeling for
my career right so i said hey mr hatcher
thanks for the look
so i'm not i can't do this i'll i'll
wait out for the program that i'm going
to go to
uh somewhere else so he he actually
called the
this fellow that ran this investment
bank and said hey get him alone on board
until he gets to the associate program
at your investment bank
and so i went but again early
they were in the middle of a big project
and um
they he
i was i joined this project so it was
kind of like process re-engineering
um but it was this is that a new company
that you're working out yes so i left i
left uh johnson higgins and went to it's
called wheat first butcher sing it's no
longer there someone bought it walk over
i think bought it
um
but imagine clearing trades again very
very exciting stuff right so imagine how
broker dealers clear trades literally
clear trades
um
you know equity trades are cleared but
also you know municipal bond trades how
the technology works and how the process
is and the regulation around clearing
those trades and how these systems have
to work together
to do that
and they had they had they had started
clearing trades for a bunch of different
mom-and-pop broker-dealers and some big
ones and so you know think about it from
a business standpoint they were bringing
in
all different types of uh people to do
trade businesses to do trades so if the
three of us started our own breaker
dealer we would hire them they do all
our back end stuff
as big as you know the big guys on the
street uh first clearing corp was the
name of it um where they would do their
work too
well anyway i got in this project to
figure out how to make that more of a
business and things like that again just
waiting out to get to investment banking
but i actually started to fall in love
with the operational component of what
we were building
and um you know i actually made the
decision and uh to decide not to go into
investment banking at that point and the
the
the consulting firm that was kind of
leading that project strategy consulting
firm called ernst young at the time
um they hired me to to work uh with them
on doing these types of projects and so
i joined them um
so i kind of left the guys hanging there
in investment banking but it's the right
choice for me i just i didn't i didn't
want to be transactional if that makes
sense i didn't want to be a middleman i
just didn't want to be in the middle i
wanted to
be building things and and i thought
giving giving input and value to what i
was doing and so fast forward um joined
austin young they said hey you can go to
new york or san francisco and and uh
that's where they have their offices and
so i went to san francisco not a big fan
of new york and
i've been there one time to be fair so
when i when i interviewed for the job
with mr hatcher
they had this big sky rise down in new
york right so you go
and they have what's called an executive
dining room
okay
and they all wear white shirts and ties
i never it's like on the 44 some big
high rise and i was going through this
executive dining hall and i
it's when i knew i didn't want to have
an executive dining hall right
so
anyway so and i hated new york so i
moved we moved to san francis i moved to
san francisco
and and uh started my career there and
came in one of the
biggest mentors that i met in my life
shortly thereafter was a guy that uh was
the ceo of the nasdaq stock market
a guy named pat campbell also served air
force but
he kind of took me under his wing and at
the time the nasdaq
was was on a buying bench they were
trying to buy up stock exchanges and
they bought the american stock exchange
which is really an option exchange and
and
i worked for him um
as ernst young doing what's called post
merger integration pmi so merging these
two companies together and it was
like it was fun um
putting two companies together
understanding how that works
frankly we do that now groundwork so
that was that was that was a good
learning process for me
and then a few years later not even a
few years later maybe 18 months later i
got this call
from my friend bob hatcher he's and uh
he says hey malone i want you to meet a
guy
and i said yes sir mr whatever you want
you know this guy's
he's really helped me
and so i'm living in san francisco and
he says hey i need to go to san diego go
meet him in san diego
are you communicating with him on a
regular basis
he's just reaching out to you yeah
so you just made such a good impression
over
pouring him scotch over those years
whatever gigs you did for him you did a
good job built a good relationship with
him and he liked you
i think so i think he identified with
being
he just loves scrappy grinders i mean to
be fair that's that's what it was he
just he i think he saw himself and me
and when you see you see the like-kind
young guys you want to help and i think
this was this is his way of helping now
mind you his way of helping was just a
little push and a little nod like he
didn't
make it happen all that made in some
cases he did but he didn't you know he
he was just he was there to help push
and prod and
uh look it changed the course of my life
this one guy
where i was tending bar in some college
to try to pay my way
and
change the trajectory of my whole life
and anyway so he calls jock he calls
of course i'd never been to san diego uh
sane was good to me like i've been here
a couple times and big things happen
when i get here
so uh so i hop on the flight from san
francisco and you know this was again
this was probably
in 97.
you know
technology you know we don't have
smartphones right um it was i was going
to meet a guy right so i get on i get in
the yellow cab
no uber at that time and
and i give the the driver the address
and we're we're scooting along and he's
like you sure this is the address
i'm like hey this is the address i
checked to see yeah this is the address
so you know five minutes later he's like
uh might you have a suit on right
meeting a guy he says uh hey bro you
sure this is the address and i'm like uh
what's the only address i have why do
you keep saying that he says well you're
you're going to san diego zoo
hi luis i said bob just punked
me you know that's
literally what i thought is it's okay i
said well look there's only a dress i
have so i'm going to continue on so we
went to the san diego zoo and i got out
and there was a
this is in the evening times about five
o'clock and people were leaving but
there was a little side thing that they
were having this event for
and they had you know partitioned it off
so i go there and i meet the guy i'm
interviewing with
his name is marvin bush
and marvin was the son of 41 and the
brother of 43
and he owned a hedge fund and a private
equity fund back in d.c
and bob and he were friends and
the way i understand the story that
marvin was at a party with him and bob
was an investor by the way in his firm
called winston partners
and
and marvin was saying look i really i
really need a young scrappy guy to come
join my team boom and bob says hey i got
a guy
so i go to san diego of course i meet
marvin san diego and uh boom got the job
and this was so this was the late 90s
when so think about this so private
equity
at the time so private equity for your
listener so private equity is is is a
unique category um in the sense of it's
an alternative investment category
if you think if you think about why it
even exists
you know many of the investors in
private equity tend to be pension funds
and colleges and endowments
and
just the unfunded liabilities for
example with pension funds today so
unfunded liabilities would be the the
difference between what they owe their
their
the folks that are part of that pension
and what assets that they have
there's always a big delta they always
have to pay out more than they have
because the cost of medical and whatever
the pain from a pension standpoint is
higher than what they have so they have
to invest that money
they invest that money in a lot of
different vehicles including public
markets but also private vehicles
alternative vehicles
of which
private equity is an alternative vehicle
like if you were to look today it's it's
striking that the
the unfunded liabilities for pension
funds in the united states is something
like 3.8 trillion
so they're trying to make this up how
are they making this up they're making
it up through hedge funds and private
equity where they get a outsized return
vis-a-vis the public markets or
vis-a-vis
you know bonds
and um
so the growth that you've seen in
private equity when i joined this
private equity firm that marvin was
running
so this would this would be
98.99
the number of private equity firms at
that time were under a thousand
if you were to look at it today there's
there's there's somewhere around 4 000
private equity firms
and they got they manage 5.8 trillion
dollars
so back when when i joined this private
equity firm it was
there was a category but it was kind of
new
but i knew i wanted to be in it and by
the way so private equity and venture
capital same category but different kind
of investment focus growth capital is
different than buyout things like that
well winston was a buyout shop and a
micro cap buyout shop which meant that
they focused on companies sub 50 million
dollars in total enterprise value
and he was looking to add
an analyst an associate to that team and
you know he bob mentioned you need to go
hire this guy so move back to
just outside of washington dc and mind
you look
this is kind of surreal for me right so
went to college
flying around with nasdaq to buy
stock exchanges
that's weird
then
working for the president's brother you
know
super nice guy super smart hated
politics but legitimate businessman and
learned a ton from him
um
you know i get to this office
and then outside of dc and mclean i
thought bro i made it this is like this
is the pinnacle man like i grew up in
ocean view you know
so
um
couldn't afford to go anything and so
you're here and it's it's very surreal
and i remember
maybe three or four months into the job
and i have my main job my own office
which is a big deal uh marvin walks in
and he sits down just as
just like this
and he kind of sits back and he says uh
maddie he called me maddie don't call me
that well maybe you can because you're a
monster but
um he says uh
maddie do you trust me
what do you think i said yep
i said no
okay
i said no i don't even know you
and that was a turning point in my
career
in the sense that so that's why i was
there is
so at this firm there are guys from
harvard business school and wharton
double you know my direct boss was a guy
named steve fry who i still work with
today he went to double uva i mean
legitimate colleges right and then you
got some knuckle dragger like me
the colleges you've never heard of
but what i think what marvin wanted was
a mutt
and um what that means is what i've
later learned what that means is so a
guy that will always speak the truth
whatever he believes the truth will be
the truth is for him
and i think he realized that i wasn't
looking to climb the ladder like i
wasn't just a yes man
and i was just so raw
either naive or stupid i really wanted
to find it i was just so raw
he loved it and he he slapped the table
walked out my office and said that's why
you're my mother
that was it right off it's good so um
that that was a
that yeah
in retrospect you know that was a big
turning point in my career and he you
know he involved me and everything and
there was some trust there because i
just wasn't one of those yes man and i
look the guys that i worked are super
smart super talented guys
um but i felt like i needed to stay
there and earn my spot so i outworked
them
and
you know mom said a long time ago and
i'm embarrassed to say this but she said
honey you're not the smartest one
they've ever created but if you work 10
harder you'll be just fine
and that's literally how i've lived my
whole life and my careers i will not be
outworked in my mind right so i will not
be outworked and so
i always figured
if i come in an hour before they do
that you know that's that for me at that
point that was five to six hours more a
week if i stayed an hour later you
double that right at the end of the year
effectively i've gained a month of
working time on them
and you also set the tone right so you
set the tone is that young guys here
longer than me
and that's another good message you know
my uh my good friend and partner ken
mcdonald we call it garden the castle i
still do it today so i like to be the
first in and last out
even at this big company that i run
because it sets the tone that you know
i'm not some executive that's going to
mail it in if we're going to go after
our mission we're going to go after and
i'm going to be there do it with you
and so
at winston i spent close to eight years
there doing deals so private equity
deals so we would buy companies
um and invest and i wouldn't operate
them you know so at this point this
traditional private equity we'd buy
these small companies we would invest in
them
sit on the boards
uh you know try to
provide wisdom but in reality just
really providing capital and trying to
direct them to good outcomes as a
business guy and so
um
i enjoyed it i loved and frankly i loved
working with entrepreneurs because so
these are small companies right so
they're not as sophisticated as you get
upstream you get large cat companies you
have professional managers you have
um
you know professional investment bankers
that that are involved
you're still buying companies that's
being operated by the founders 100 yes
100 and it was perfect for street
fighters i loved it
you know there's no like harvard mbas
running around kind of managing their
guys literally
working
you know if it's a construction company
for example they're literally driving
hard equipment they're managing their
they're doing the work themselves while
trying to manage the business and so
i thought i could add value many of
those cases and and uh that frankly is
kind of where i cut my teeth for what i
wanted to do learning and watching these
founders and what i would pay them for
their businesses
i would sit there and go my god this
guy's about to make you know 50 large
and
i think i can do that you know
you know and so uh i did that for a few
years
almost eight years
great team great uh marvin
and i you know he's
uh he took a chance on me um
um
i mean he didn't need to jiago and that
guy uh you know he comes from a great
family but this guy also he burned the
midnight and worked hard and it was a
pleasure working for him but
he comes in
he comes in one day and says uh hey
matty you might want to get your cv
together this is
cv is fancy for resume and
uh
i was like oh man something big is going
on or i just got fired i'm not sure
which
and uh it turned out they were he had a
partner and they were separating the
firm you know talk about you know
partnerships sometimes don't last
forever and so they were going to
separate the firm
never forget this so i get up out of my
my sweet office and i walk down the hall
to marvin and i said hey mar i think i'm
going to i think i'm going to go i think
you know you don't want to be part of a
firm that's kind of in disarray
said i think i'm gonna go try something
else and
he says uh he says mad i knew you'd come
down here and uh
literally um
i ended up
a couple days later meeting with uh
a guy named
ray hunt
in dallas so ray hunt is
at the time was fortune 50 which means
he's a 50 is one of the 50th rich
richest fellows on the planet
he owned a big oil business
but he also owned his own big
alternative investment group when you
got that kind of money
you invest your own money right so he
had a team of folks that did all
alternative investments so from real
estate to venture capital to leverage
buyout
and i joined his leveraged buyout team
and was offered the opportunity to look
all their offices were in dallas and and
i was given the opportunity to make open
their first office outside of dallas
which is a big deal i was going to build
my own team to leave my own deals
and so you know i got to pick atlanta or
charlotte to do that and i opened my my
office for hunt private equity in
charlotte north carolina and did you
know did some cool deals
it was fun uh
again think about the progression here
of
marvin to to ray and these are some you
know players players as they say right
so uh
fast forward a few years as you this was
in 0-809 the world's going badly oh yeah
so what was the how'd that all work out
well we had at that time we only had
three active portfolio companies we just
started actively investing and came all
three of those were my companies
and there was kind of this decision to
make um about what are we gonna do with
these companies if things go really bad
how are we gonna support them things
like that and mind you hunt although you
know
very wealthy he has other interests in
particular energy and running energy
company takes a lot of capital
um
and so
my hair brain was i was going to buy the
portfolio from mr haunt and um
and so i
i went down there and i offered to buy
the portfolio and i
he agreed
and how did you structure that deal so
three active portfolio companies so i
knew the enterprise values of all of
them and mind you look i didn't have the
money to do it that's why i'm asking you
how you structure that you you talk
about hustling you would love this chaka
so
um so i got him to agree to the deal
right what was going to be so total
enterprise put them all together what
the total purchase price would be what
the return looked like for him
we would take these portfolio companies
into a new fund
now then i once you said yes i was
running around trying to raise the money
for said investment vehicle
to buy this portfolio got it so you did
a little raise
attempted to do a little bit because
this is what 2008 2009 yeah so you
weren't raising much
well the ironic thing is i i i found the
the firms to back me
we were going to pull it off but the
companies that we had invested in were
performing so well
literally these are these are kind of uh
recession-proof businesses that
a billionaire says no i i'm deciding not
to sell these companies that's what he
does and so he didn't we would enable
able to to pull off that transaction and
mind you i have any money
so i'm i've spent so he so wait so he
reneged a little bit
careful here that's the hardest thing to
say he made a different decision
he decided he was going to keep him yes
sir got it yes sir
and he's prerogative
he looked at the performance he said man
i'm not losing money these things can
last forever i'm going to keep them and
so he did
he did
and so
envision this when you go to your boss
and say hey i'm going to take you out i
want to take this a different strategy i
know the economy is terrible you're
going to focus on energy i'm going to
buy this portfolio
it doesn't bode well for your career so
that was kind of my end of my career
there at hunt
um so
i had started this firm that i called at
the time i was doing the raise with
these other private equity firms
called succession capital and it's a
private equity firm i own today and and
the the phrase succession literally
means
when you think about all the great
businesses built by boomers of the of
the last 50 years
and i'd always thought to myself look
i'm going to have my own private equity
if i'm going to buy my own companies and
if you looked at all the folks that
needed to retire the boomers needed to
retire and the data really is clear on
this that
second second generation businesses
never work thirty percent success rate
third generation businesses around 12
percent
i think that that's incredible right so
you have all this wealth that's been
created locked up in these businesses
um so we got the boomer creates the
business yes
and that's business is doing great when
that boomer steps away
it's got a 30 chance of survival if you
give it to your kids if you give it two
kids and if that
survives you got a 12 i mean it goes to
the next set of kids
this is a classic
classic we see this over and over again
right right right well look they don't
work to get it yeah they never struggle
they never went through everything
that's required to get it right so hey
man if daddy gives you a business and
you just show up the business starts
interfering with my golf game because
that's not happening exactly
so that was kind of my mindset it's like
you have all this pent up value in these
companies and small companies and that i
would just go and buy them and allow
that owner
to monetize their life's work
and
and some of this you you probably
recognize this so some of the smart
business owners they know they're not
giving it to their kids
we see it every day today and some of
the businesses that i buy not that
they're bad kids but
they're not going to run a business
they're not going to run a business and
the owner the person that built it they
want the money to live whatever
lifestyle they have left they don't want
the company to slowly pay them out
because think about this how would a kid
buy a business well only way to do it is
that the company that they were given
finances that exit for the for the for
the parents well
you can't fly around the world enjoying
life if that's how it's done
and so my pitch to some of these owners
was hey look uh succession will buy you
i'll allow you to
monetize that great build and then go
live your life and do your thing and um
so that that notion was was was always
in my mind
after you know doing private equity at
that point for you know 15 years or 13
years or something like that it was
always in my mind and then the event at
hunt
kind of catapult that right into
existence
and i formed it i was going to put these
three portfolio companies in there and
then you know i ran around spent you
know i don't know 150 000 of my own
money trying to get this thing off the
ground
and you know of course that's all zeroed
out at that point because we couldn't
buy the portfolio and so
here i am in charlotte
i had enough money to kind of keep me
plugging away for uh maybe a year 15
months
my goal was to find try to find a
company that's what i was going to say
you're still sitting on the money that
you raised no no no okay so you didn't
do that never closed never closed got it
we turned the purchase agreement twice
that's a tough one
it's tough on me like oh god
yeah
anyway
hey good lesson never go against a
billionaire
i've done that twice in my career and
i've definitely lost twice
so uh i'm a slow runner sometimes i
guess
so i'm sitting there in charlotte trying
to find businesses and the problem the
charlotte's a great city the problem
with charlotte though it's full of what
you know commercial bankers and
investment bankers that all are looking
for little businesses they can buy so
they can
and there might have lifestyle
businesses right so it's pretty
competitive to find a business in that
market
as i'm looking for businesses um i had a
friend
jimmy flowers that um
that you know we had bought one piece of
real estate jocko that uh that so
wachovia was melting down at this point
so this was like during the great
recession right so wachovia so what year
are we talking 80809 okay
good
rough brutal right now so i try to make
it run the portfolio got nothing um and
you know
i really can't really get a job i could
get a job i just refuse to get a job you
know i'm gonna make a run at this
so i'm looking at myself are you married
at this point yeah you got kids
yeah my my son aiden alone is uh yeah
yeah yeah that's it's not fun yeah
because i mean you can just get away
with anything when you're single no kids
you're like okay cool i'll sleep you
know i'll sleep in the van it's all good
we can make it work well you got the
wife and kids you know the phrase burn
the boats yeah yeah man that was it like
i was i was not gonna lose now i didn't
have a path to like where that was going
yeah i've had that discussion
i had that discussion with my wife um
and i've told people about this you got
to figure out what your minimum standard
is and you got to figure out what your
wife's minimum standard is and i had the
conversation with my wife a few times
where i was saying look if this doesn't
work
i'm good
with living in our rv and we're gonna
travel up and down the coast of
california and i'm gonna surf and we're
gonna hang out we're gonna go to a bunch
of different jujitsu schools and
we'll live off my navy retirement
and i'm good with that i need to check
if you're good with that and she's like
oh it sounds good sounds like fun i'll
get to see you more and i was like okay
cool
you got to figure out what that minimum
standard is going to be because if the
minimum standard is hey i at least need
a house or i at least need a house you
know with three bedrooms or four what's
the minimum standard you got to have
that conversation sometimes and i gave
this advice on on the academy the other
day someone was asking about you know
i'm going through this transition period
how do i address it with my wife
and i said look you're going to take
risk not just with you but it's with
your wife figure out what the minimum
standard is and then make your decisions
and and that you have a lot your minimum
standard is a lot lower when you're a
solo dude right you're flying like
there's no minimum i really didn't even
have a minimum standard as a person
right as an individual i had no minimum
standard i could survive literally
perfect yeah yeah we'll get it done yeah
but figure out what that minimum
standard is so we're so you had your
wife you had kids
so my wife was your wife okay would live
in a van down by the river she would
have been yeah yeah that's what i'm
talking about she ride or die best thing
ever happened to me so sarah's uh is all
in she's always been all in uh
yeah you need that when you do when you
when you know it looks from now you look
back and say oh yeah easy life right
because i've been pretty successful
today but
bro back in the day it was it was it was
not always this uh rosy and
you know her being you know 100
supportive tells you everything you need
to know when when it when when when
things are hitting everything is great
it's easy to have a relationship right
but when things are bad and you don't
know
and we had some money we weren't living
on the street but you know it was it was
running out fast
christmas i'm breaking out the spam hey
mom what's that recipe
uh
so
um you know i'm just again at this point
just scrapping right i'm hustling like
like nobody's business and um we're
sitting there we're looking for
businesses and and uh we get a call from
um
a fella that a a family office in
chicago billionaire that had put uh a
lot of money in a mess fund so a mess
fund for your listeners is you know you
got you got traditional equity where you
you know you you put in your money you
don't get
a a kind of dividend or annual return
you get the upside and the gain
debt of course is your traditional debt
where you have to pay some kind of
interest on it mez is in between well
you have a mezzanine
strip or mesdet where
you get an elevated dividend so it's
it's higher than a bank the risk is
higher too but you pay more than a bank
you'd have to charge a bank our bank
would charge you but you also get a
little bit of equity upside it was it's
popular in real estate so
he calls um my friend jimmy uh gets the
thing and says the call and says hey
yeah
they knew jimmy and they said hey look
we have this
mez investment in this fund and this and
they they're holding this thing at cost
which this thing would be this big
building and surely it was charlotte it
was it was a big construction project
they had
and if you're in 09 and 08 if you're
holding something at cost you're lying
because because they're saying hey look
you put 10 million dollars into this
we're telling you it's still worth 10.
so the guy calls and says hey flowers
it ain't worth 10.
so um flyer says hey let's go check this
out so we're hoping to hop in the truck
we drive to this building
we look it's a 109 unit building and and
uh it's literally empty
it's literally like residential like
residential multi multi-family
residential condo development
so uh we're looking at each other and
with of course we're scrappers like how
do we monetize this yeah you're looking
at that thing let's let that thing like
it's a hamburger
i don't know much about real estate but
i do now um
so uh we looked and jim said we just get
a fee we can help this guy
and i said no no no we're gonna
we're gonna do something different so
i called a guy that i knew in town um uh
that is the project done done oh worst
case scenario right so if it's in
construction you kind of delay it a
little bit so that you can finish it and
sell at an optimal price as as the
economy recovers right
this came online the average square foot
cost of this building was likely 3x
overvalued so if you're buying a condo
in charlotte at this point and you're
paying this price you're you're a fool
it's it's 3x too expensive which means
by the way your your mez debt and your
equity probably worth nothing
so we do this work and we call the guys
back and say uh hey listen uh we're
gonna come see you tomorrow
now mind you broke again we're flying
coach to charlotte back of the bus right
next to the lav and
uh we're we're getting up there and i
put this big proposal together and
so we get up there and and our pitch was
simply this hey look um
i had met the guy uh that night i called
the banker that i knew who actually was
banking the deal from a senior
perspective
and he he controlled the debt
and he shared with me hey we're sellers
of this debt and i offered them on the
phone a number
um
mind you i didn't have the money to do
it but i said okay i'll pay you this for
it he said we're done i said well we're
good i said okay
next day i'm on the plane going up to
see these billionaires and our pitch was
simply this let's your mess is worth
zero the good news is that we're going
to buy this note
or capitalize a little more and we'll
buy this asset here's what your return
will be
you give me 18 months to sell off this
reprice the asset
and you give me a a
of some runway to start marketing this
building you're going to make a great
return
caveat being we're going to share
profits i'll do all the work
i'll literally sell the units myself
with my partner jimmy at that time
and um they agreed
now mind you like i don't know anything
about real estate at this time as a pe
guy but i could learn pretty fast and no
offense is not that complicated right so
we got effort so our first big project
succession was really
a real estate project so we disposed of
all those assets made a lot of money and
um
second lesson from a billionaire so
we're making so much money the final
payment um the guy calls and says hey
you guys are making too much money
we're like hey well that's that's the
agreement we're going to share the
profits we put in the work you know we
two
roughly roughly 19 months of hard labor
to sell these units 109 unit building
and he said no no i want another half a
million
so what do you say
you said yes sir i mean what are you
going to do
he literally said look i'll tie you up
in court for five years you'll never see
that money i'm like
okay well there you go so another lesson
a hard lesson um but we did that that
frankly helped me capitalize succession
and allowed me to kind of push our our
model to where it is today i knew i
didn't want to be in the real estate
game although we have a real estate
division today income producing
properties
um we have about 30 income producing
properties today
it's a great business um jimmy flowers
my partner runs the real estate
component of that but my passion is
operating companies and so
we now now having a little bit of
capital and you know no lean christmas
at least that year
uh
um we um i found a company so ultimately
found a company back in norfolk that was
called petrochem
uh recovery i bought this business from
the fenska family super family it was
the environmental services space so
think
anything that can't go in a water
treatment facility or a landfill this
company would clean up and dispose of
great family great business not as you
can i don't know anything about that
either
but literally i wanted to cut my teeth
on being a true operator so i bought the
company 23 employees
um literally a thousand square foot
office
uh mind you so think about this i'm
flying around in private planes working
with some of the biggest guys in the
world
now i'm in norfolk at 1635 multi avenue
a thousand square foot building
moving hazardous waste around my my
office literally was like it has like
the
the old wooden plywoo uh wood like
they're not real wood it's like that
plywood stuff
oh i mean like wood paneling yeah what
panel right like you'd see like
70s and stuff right yes
so you know that's literally where my
office was and and right next door to
that was the shooter so it's always a
good morning when you have 23 people
using one bathroom but
um
but you know i loved it loved every
minute of it so i got my has whopper
certification learned to drive a vac
truck if necessary although rarely
but i was able to at that point engage
in a business from operational
standpoint
leverage everything that i'd learned in
private equity over the years in terms
of investing in process technology
people
and
started to realize the importance of
investing in
skilled tradesmen and women
and it wasn't really until i got there
that i realized a deficit in the country
as it relates to skilled trades now
we'll talk a little bit about that in a
minute but so built that company
we actually tripled that business in
about two years
making so much money from that business
that i was able to buy another company
called shipyard staffing so that that
business is skill trade labor to the
shipyards
so we we initial business we eyeball was
little we rebranded it to shipyard
staffing again true skill trade so i
think welders pipefitters ship builders
ship fitters
great men and women so this company
would provide temporary skilled labor to
the shipyards as they would build you
know boats
for your listeners out there like when
you build a navy vessel there's a lot of
peak demand for labor at certain points
of the construction and so what what
companies like ours would do provide
that peak labor to allow them to
continue on production and do it in a
more efficient manner um so built that
bought that business built it we opened
up we had an office in norfolk newport
news where they built all the aircraft
carriers as you know we opened up in
jacksonville florida another navy base
we opened up here in san diego the last
time i was in san diego i signed a lease
for a property down the road
so it's been good to me and then
bremberton which is uh near seattle
that business again
for me
it really showed me that the deficit of
skilled tradesmen and women in this
country is a problem
for for not only my business but for the
country so the average age of a welder
for us
was like 54.
think about that for one second like if
you think about how this country is
going to protect itself and build and
and repair
just our warships
in our our aging workforce what are we
going to do in 10 years
it's a real
national security issue that no one
really talks about i think
we could talk a lot about this but
you know the push for college
of the last 20 30 years if you look at
the stats i think since 1990
college enrollment's up 60 percent
cost adjusted for inflation is up like
300 percent
subsidized just 100 percent that's hot
subsidized by the government you're
making loans just like just like the
mortgage just like the mortgage crash
they're making loans to people
that
aren't necessarily gonna be able to pay
those loans back because you go to
college for four years and it costs
three hundred and eighty thousand
dollars and the job that you get with
your degree when you leave that school
is a thirty two thousand dollar or
thirty eight thousand dollar your job
that's what that's what's happening
so it's a disaster
and there's an impending cliff here and
i know you feel strongly about bringing
manufacturing back to united states
if we don't start building skilled
trades men and women in this country
there will be a colossal collapse
um think about everything we do like all
these great high-tech companies and
everything they do well someone's got to
run the electrician electrician lines
there or the gas lines there or build
those skyscrapers or whatever it might
be
the the blue-collar skill-trade men and
women in this country have been
forgotten
and um you know it really came to roost
for me as we started building out
shipyard staffing because the age
really scared me right and so crazy
look our strategy there uh pretty simple
so i i got a secret clearance there so i
threw my company
my idea was
to provide skilled trade labor to
you know true u.s navy shipyards and
nuclear vessels
uh so i could pay my guys more we could
grow our business and that's what we did
so we grew that business quadrupled that
business and pretty fast which is great
we opened as you know a bunch of new
offices
and uh like i
of course i thought hey man i'm i'm
building some great value in these
portfolio companies i'm having fun
um and then i and then i met a guy that
uh that kind of changed the course of my
career as we got into groundwork so i a
friend of mine calls and says hey listen
i i'm building this software company and
i'd like to pitch you on the idea
you and some other guys
and i went to college with this guy and
i say bro i'm never going to invest with
you you know you're one of those guys a
good guy but never going to put my money
behind him and plus i what do i know
about software i'm a blue collar
investor i i like to invest in companies
that actually do things
manufacture things or service things or
those types of things and so
um i go because i know him i'm we're
friends or i go i go to this big fancy
you know
uh conference room and i walk in and
there's a guy sitting next to me and his
uh it's a tax account and i'm like uh
hey bro what are you doing here he said
what do you mean i said you ain't got no
money wait and he says yeah i know he
told me to come and fill the seats he's
putting on the show
i'm like that's why i'm here
and i i i whispered to him i said uh
well who's the dude with the money is
there anyone here we're just looking at
each other is he practicing supposed to
be some guy named matt
so he looks across the table and there's
a guy there um a guy named jesse waltz
and and he was the guy one of the guys
that had real money and then in the room
and so we listened to the pitch whatever
but the tax guys is also his tax guy
and he says the jesse hey you and matt
need to have dinner tonight so we have
dinner
and jesse owned a couple companies one
company was a software company and we're
having dinner and he's telling me about
the software business it's like a crm or
erp combo for this industry
that's around
foundation repair
waterproofing crawl space encapsulation
i like to refer to it as water
management displacement sure
consumers don't know what that means but
in the investment world that's what we
call it
and he's talking about the software
business right and i'm literally
thinking i gotta get out of here this is
this is ridiculous and no offense look
virginia beach is not the hub for
software development
what's so funny echo yes
so i'm thinking okay this this can't be
a world-class company but as we as he
continues to talk
he discloses that the aggregate revenue
running through his software was over
800 million dollars
i think oh
not his business but the the businesses
that were using his that's like oh i
mean i better pay attention
so as i sit there and listen to learn
more about the industry um i literally
had this crazy idea so i go home
that night and literally get on the
internet and start searching to kind of
size the industry because my mind was
like he's doing 800 million
again no offense to anyone in virginia
beach doing software but i didn't think
he could have fifty percent of the
market twenty percent of the market i
thought okay wow he probably didn't have
ten percent of the market but this
industry has kind of been forgotten and
there's no industry association for this
specific industry so mostly you have an
association windows roofing you can size
the size of the category we couldn't do
that here
so my idea was was simply this look i
pitched them and i put the proposal
together that night
and i
i remember my wife sarah's like you're
just a
crazy man
um so i put this proposal together
jacqueline it was simply this i'll buy
your software business i'm sorry i'll
buy your service business he owned a
service business as well called jes i'll
buy that service business
you can capitalize your software
business with the proceeds of the
service business that i was going to buy
so he invented the software business to
support his foundation business
and i said look i ain't going to buy
that software business but i'll buy the
service business you do your own thing
knock yourself out so like at 4 30 in
the morning about to send this thing of
course sarah says hey you idiot don't
don't do that uh she says that a lot so
i wait till like 7 30 truthfully send
this thing out
and um
and the rest is history i mean so jesse
uh we agreed uh to terms like three or
four months after that and i bought this
company called jes foundation repair
virginia beach and they had at that time
they had three offices one in manassas
which is effectively washington dc one
in richmond one in virginia beach
and he had owned another business that
candidly i think he bought right before
i bought him to get some arb on the on
the trade in indiana called indiana
foundation so we started with these four
locations
and aggregate revenue roughly 30 million
dollars about 190 employees
um
in my mind this what i wanted to do was
build a national
foundation services business with this
platform because i had i had seen there
was no national player it was because
there was no association i couldn't find
a national player
and i really cut my teeth on these other
businesses and kind of beli really
felt like
i was in a position to bring the
leadership capital process technology to
an industry that time had forgotten and
you mentioned it on the outset we are
really in the construction business but
we don't talk that way we talk consumer
so day one we are consumer business we
don't talk construction we are certainly
construction company that's what we do
but we
we go to market as a consumer business
um and the way frankly the consumer has
evolved over the last 10 years if you
don't go to business like that you're
going to lose and
we win a lot of the
the business because think about your
experience with contractors today
it's typically horrible you know they
say they show up they don't show up they
say you know you know they're going to
send you a bill they don't so it's it's
not a great process for consumers
our notion was simply we're going to
build a company that puts a puts a
consumer first that builds a national
business
but at the same time
build a unique
skilled trades business that honors the
men and women of this industry well they
can have a profession and not a job
and i learned that mindset through
petrochem and shipyard staffing and it
it's become kind of a
not kind of it has become an obsession
of mine to build businesses where
we celebrate men and women that um you
know get it done
um not just with their mind but with
their hands because without them this
country falls apart
so that was how groundworks was born
and uh so that was in that was in may of
2016 we bought our
this first company and
you know i think i
when i met you i saw of course i
this you might forget this but so i of
course
read extreme ownership early on
and uh
probably late 16 i think the book came
out in 15 but late 16 i read the book
and it really resonated with me
especially as it related to groundworks
in the sense that think about what we do
so we we we are decentralized business
our crews are three-man crews if we can
get them
um
trained on the laws of combat as as you
define them you know
and as we live them
you can empower a business to do
remarkable things right and
so we adopted this mindset of extreme
ownership within the company
and i'll never forget so uh early on it
was it was pretty i had some struggles
so i bought a company i had to fix up a
little bit to be fair
and so i went to the muster uh and dc
muscle wrote three
what year was that i think was 18 okay
and uh
so
i didn't share this but look every penny
i had winning this company i literally
moved back in but mom
to buy this company
with a wife and a child so
yeah so that was a lean christmas um
christmas
and that's why your wife was like don't
send that freaking email jackass
that's our money that's right
so to to make a run at this we put
everything in and and you know you i
hear you talk quite a bit but to be
successful in anything there has to be a
degree of obsession
there's no plan b for us here it is this
is it there's we're all in on this and
there's it has to work and it will work
because i'll put everything we have into
to making it work
and so um we're cleaning up a few things
that we needed to we spent probably over
a million dollars of going back and
doing jobs for consumers to do them
correctly
and um so
the price tag for the musters it's it's
it's real and so um
i was going to bring some of my leaders
and i have a partner so this fellow
jesse waltz invested back into the
business with me and he's a minority
shareholder at the time and and uh
you know i was like i can't run this
through the company because uh you know
he's not really happy with me at the
moment anyway even though he was a
minority guy i wanted to keep them happy
and respect him so i tell the wife hey
guess what uh is it okay if i spend x
amount of dollars to go this mustard i'm
gonna bring these guys
and you can imagine the look you're like
what are you doing right so
go to the muster i bring eight guys uh
one guy's one of my best friends a guy
named tom girardi who doesn't work for
me but is a huge fan of yours
and he was like you got to go these
musters and i'm like bro you ever been
to a muster he said no
and
by the way he played football at harvard
so he's he's a bond trader he ain't
worried about living with mama but he's
like maloney i'll pay my own way i said
you should pay my way
so we go we go to uh we go to the muster
and and candidly
it
and i say this internally with my guys i
was like man this is going to either be
like some tony robbins we're
going to hug it out and sing kumbaya and
i'd be a waste of money or it's going to
be the real deal and it was the real
deal it was literally the real deal
and i said i got to get me some of this
i got to figure out a way to weave the
mindset
and the cadence of what we talked about
and all all the laws
into our business to empower this
business to be as special as i want it
to be if you're gonna make investments
in people
and you're gonna you're gonna build a
business where
the profession is honored
you have to give them the tools in order
to do it you just can't you know for
example chuck we can teach sales we can
teach production
but how do you teach leadership
how do you really teach it and how do
you measure its effect and what's the
return on investment on that
and that was look the way you did it
and late did it the seal teams and and
how you wrote about it i said well
there's no one on the planet that can do
i mean if he can't do it for us it can't
be done right so i'm driving back from
dc and i'm all jacked up
and i call i don't know about that back
in the day your headquarters were in
seattle yeah so we call out to seattle
and
and uh i get a young guy on the phone
and he's like listen we don't really we
don't really do long-term programs if
we're effective at what we do
we don't really need to be there because
i pitched him on hey look i want a
multi-year deal
so that i can i can send new leaders
through this program constantly so that
i can transform my business so that we
have a bunch of savages walking around
that care about the customer care about
themselves and are passionate about
leadership and development
and um
so he said no initially and then so we
called back said look i don't think i've
explained myself right away here's kind
of what we're looking for
and uh so yeah that interesting little
backstory and that that sort of is the
you know failure on my part because one
of the things that i would tell the team
at echelon front is i'd say listen i
don't want to be like these consulting
companies that go in and hang on and put
their hooks in and claws in and they
they're just gonna milk company for
everything that they're worth listen
guys if we're doing our job correctly
we're not there for five years we're
there for six months we're there for a
year they understand these principles
and they take them and run with them
what i didn't clarify
is hey if we've got a company that's
growing rapidly
we may need to help them along the way
and
and that happened with other companies
and your companies one of the ones that
it happened to it was happening too very
fast and so i had to kind of i i mean i
forget how it got back to me but i
remember rebriefing the team and saying
listen if we have a client that's
growing rapidly
we can train all their trainers but
they're still gonna need people they're
just gonna need support i mean you when
you when you're absorbing two or three
companies a year that have two or three
hundred people each
they're probably going to need help yeah
we need to help them so there's a little
backstory there yeah
well they they certainly echoed your
first sentiments right away they they
said no no we and and it makes sense but
we had to really explain look it's not
the same people going through the
program
and
you know caleb at that time we didn't
have the bandwidth to have true trainers
we were okay we're going to hire the
firm we're going to send new leaders new
new leaders to the process and
like our growth rate we are acquiring
businesses
and we wanted to make sure that those
uh they keep their culture we celebrate
that culture um you know our average
brand that groundworks is over 26 years
old of the companies we buy
we buy businesses as small as 3 million
as large as 80.
so they're big dichotomy in terms of the
size of the businesses
and
when we buy them we would celebrate
their culture but we're going to bring
them on to the groundworks way of
culture which you can marry those two
and the way we married them was by
leveraging extreme ownership as our
culture
and
um
so it empowers a given culture
if they embrace these things and they do
and so every acquisition now we run an
ftx for the the the partners that we've
just brought on
i think we've run 16 of those now
all kind of senior level leadership go
to musters you know we so we're gonna
send 23 folks to dallas
it's part of
our leadership development training
program at groundworks and you know we
have
i i think the last number we've spent
we've we've sent 530 folks through
training directly with the echelon front
team you know jp danelle
carlos
um
corey
cody rather
and then this this young guy flynn
cochran
back in the day uh you know they would
lead that process for us and
and really
again not to sound like a commercial but
they became part of the team like
jp knows my team and um he can relate
the stories of our business
and the construction component of our
business in a way that ties it into
extreme ownership and how it applies to
our business every day
and that is how you really learn and
that's how it's absorbed and so
um your team's done a really good job at
that for us
yeah the the
you know when you talk about merging hey
this idea this these principles into
some other company
and sometimes i'll ge i'll people will
have discussions with leaders about that
and you know well i don't know if it's
gonna i don't know if you know our
culture is gonna match and i always say
like i have like a i've answered this
question so many times
that i kind of just go oh you don't
think the culture is going to match you
you maybe think you have some different
leadership principles that you feel like
yeah you know we're just we're not the
military we weren't in the military so
we're just you know we don't have that
mindset and i said well you know let's
talk about a little bit you know for
instance we teach cover and move which
is teamwork which is supporting team are
you teaching that you should all stay in
silos and work against each other we
teach about keeping things simple
are you teaching that we should make
things so complex that no one knows
what's going on we talk about prioritize
and execute do you think that in your
company what you'd rather do is
spread yourself so thin over so many
different things at the same time that
you can't effectively do anything
is that what you're thinking and
decentralized commander are you are you
thinking that you don't want to empower
your subordinate leaders you want all
decisions to be run through some central
location and and even the idea of
extreme ownership
or what you think and is this doesn't
match with your culture because your
culture is we're going to all sit around
and blame each other and point fingers
to each other so like
there's no leadership human in the world
that disagrees with these principles
you just can't they're they're they're
universal principles that are
foundational to leading other human
beings so the fact that you've that you
recognized that that you saw oh i see
this and then the the step that you're
talking about that that jp and the rest
of the team that jp does well but he's
been working with you for a long time we
do this all the time we do with finance
companies we do with manufacturing
companies like the principles apply
to any organization
the thing that's nice is that you are
able to sit there at that muster and go
oh i see the alignment between oh
decentralized command well let's see i
got a bunch of disaggregated people i
got small elements that are going out in
the field they've got to understand how
they're going to interact with the
customer that's how we're going to get
good feedback that's how we're going to
grow our business oh okay that makes
sense oh what about prioritize and
execute oh yeah well we've got all these
things that are going to go wrong on a
job site if we don't have people that
understand
if we don't have people that understand
how to react to those things and how to
figure out what the most important thing
is and execute on that
and you just were able to to see that
and and therefore taken to go hey we
need to run with that and that's uh
that's an impressive call to make oh
well thank you
okay
in retrospect it looks like genius right
but um uh but candidly at the time it
was
it was back to that simple equation how
do you build leaders right i truly
believe that that and you've said this
mean a thousand times or more
that you can teach leadership
you can teach it and you should teach it
and you should learn to be a student of
leadership right and so look you've got
so many war heroes on this podcast i'm
the opposite of that i'm just a normal
knuckle dragger you know entrepreneur
but you don't have to be in the military
to embrace these principles you just if
you if you if you lead anything in your
life these principles apply and i'm
again just the walking example of that
and my company is as well and so
what you've seen at groundworks
is
is the belief
that if you unite people on a mission
and you empower them
and train them and believe in them
you can do the impossible
you know part of part of the notion of
groundworks and we've taken extreme
ownership a little deeper than just the
the laws of combat
at our company we have over 235 owners
so think about the decentralized
business right so today
the business again north of 800 million
we have
49 locations
at each one of those locations as a
general manager a sales manager
production manager and office manager
my manager of philosophy
before even reading the book is pretty
simple want to hire the best possible
person i could possibly hire and afford
that does change over time but you want
to do that you want to give them the
best equipment you can afford to as a
business training equipment whatever it
might need you want to
build incentive programs that allow them
as an individual to win when the company
wins
and then you want to hold them
accountable
so if you believe in that concept again
that that's pretty simple management
philosophy if you believe in that
concept and you super layer in the
principles of stream ownership and then
you say
one step further
all you leaders in the branches
you're going to be literally owners of
our business so i don't want you just to
adopt extreme ownership live that way
if you do that and you really believe it
and we as a company win
you and your family will get the benefit
of that
by ownership and so look at groundworks
we're going to make over 100
millionaires out of
this company for men and women that work
with their hands
think about how many companies out there
in the valley and software companies
startups you have all these young
and they've earned it but all these
young overnight millionaires walking
around
i always felt like you can bring that
same mindset
to a skilled trades business
you could and we're going to prove that
it can be done and by doing that i'm
going to attract world-class talent to
this business if you're at another home
services company today if you're at you
know a window company or
i won't say any company names but if
you're at any in any company
and you want to get after it
and i don't mean just believe in the
philosophy of this and also what we are
building as a company
but if you care about working with
people that care and you want to build
something unique and get rewarded for
that as a business and as an individual
to help your family
we're the only business that i think in
home service has adopted that mindset
and that's why we're winning like
groundwork success has nothing to do
with matt malone it has to do with the 4
200 people that make it up
the only thing i did was kind of push
and nudge shut the strategy
and adopt
all these different strategies not just
eo strategy but how we incent we have
profit sharing programs for example we
have good benefits you know we have a
career path where men and women can join
here and have a profession
the many of the companies that i buy man
it is a job here's why you buy a
family-owned business and mr smith is at
the top and mr smith's kids at the the
business and say it's a 10 million
dollar business you're the third man
down
how are you going to get any more money
how are you going to grow when that kind
of environment you're not going to grow
so family-owned businesses are great we
love them
but in our business i want someone on on
our staff to take my job they should
that's what we're built to do is that if
we build an environment respects the men
and women that get up every day and work
with their hands shot go in the mud like
it we have office in north dakota
and fargo these dudes are out there in
10 degrees we got offices in miami it's
110 degrees out there some days these
guys get out there protect consumers
greatest at their asset their home
it's not sexy
it's hard work but at our company we can
make a profession and a livelihood that
recruits the best possible town in the
world and home services to do something
that's never been done
and it's
it's a big dream but it's not me it's my
team the team is building it and that's
what's great about not only our company
but this country is that
you can do that you can do that here
still and you're an entrepreneur
you know what i'm talking about so
um eo has been a big big part of
our
internal mindset and culture and still
is like we have
meetings they're called cover and move
so when sales and production get
together every week to talk about their
week and the jobs that we have to do
it's literally the cover movement
meeting
deep debrief and read back that is a
those are phrases we use every day yeah
standard protocols for you guys it's
but having worked in other businesses
and owning other businesses the power of
just a read back
it's hard to explain i even use it with
my wife what she hates let me give read
back on that here's what i heard
or your kids
uh my logan i i i said okay
we just discussed this
tell me what daddy just said you know so
you know you live it
but to you know look to to some of your
listeners out there that are in the
service are thinking about getting out
of service one day to all the business
guys out there all the entrepreneurs
um
look it's real
it's real if you bel if you adopt it and
live it it's real and uh i have this
phrase that i use all the time
internally it's uh
you get the life you give yourself
like there are externalities that have
happened in your life and sometimes you
can't affect them can't you can't do
anything about them but at the end of
the day
if you decide to get up you have the
discipline to get up and get effort
every day and you make it a priority
you can change the course of your life
and all we're doing is at groundworks is
using that mindset on a business that
changes 4 200 lives
it sounds cool now
but when when you know those slim
christmases when you know when and i'm
begging my wife to
to allow us to send you know eight dudes
to a muster in dc it wasn't that way
so
the uh the the the investment that you
make right so this is this is the thing
that's very interesting you you are
investing in your leaders and you've
been investing your leaders you know
what uh when i got back from my last
deployment when i was in ramadi came
back
and
took over the west coast training and i
was just
so focused charles focused on the
shooters focused on making sure that the
young guys understood that as
seals they needed to be thinking
shooters absolutely but i really really
was focused on the leadership and making
sure that the leadersh leaders
understood how to lead
and
it was one of the things that really
opened my eyes
on that deployment and really on
previous my previous deployments through
my whole career the army and the marine
corps
had absolutely professionalized and
doctrinalized how they trained leaders
so
the the the army
the army would go to this uh the the
company career course their career
course they call it which is a company
level commander
and this is like a six month or a
year-long school that these guys would
get trained on how to lead their troops
and they have that at every level
enlisted and officer in the army and in
the marine corps
and in the seal teams there was almost
nothing there was almost nothing there
was a little junior officer training
course that was uh leif ended up taking
it over when he took it over it was hey
this is where you're gonna learn how to
write evaluations this is gonna you're
gonna learn a little bit about writing
navy navy message traffic it was
and you'd get some debriefs on some
stuff but you weren't going to actually
learn
any principles of leadership
and it was just it was unbelievable
that this was taking place and i
remember as i started to try and push
this hard
the i went i started going up my chain
of command and one of the things that i
bring up the chain of command was was
hamburger university and hamburger
university if you don't know
it's up in
um
i think it's in schaumburg illinois
but if you're going to run a mcdonald's
you've got to go to this this course and
it's like a six-month school that you go
to
and so i remember sitting down with my
boss and saying hey have you heard of
hamburger universities and what's that i
said it's if you're going to run a
freaking mcdonald's
you're going to go to a six-month
training course on how to lead a
mcdonald's where you flip burgers and
and fry french fries and we've got guys
that have are going to go out and and
oversee combat operations and have lives
at risk and we give them they don't go
to any school
this is a problem and and part of the
problem is because
we're a victim of our own success so hey
you know hey jocko you just went on
deployment you came back you did a good
job you were in charge okay so what
we're doing is working
and hey this other guy you know leifa
you you did good you got mentored and
you got trained up so that what we're
doing the on-the-job training works
and and it does work sometimes
but but it also fails sometimes and this
is so now we find this in every industry
every industry hey oh we
we got we got echo charles here he's a
good salesman
in fact he's our best salesman let's put
him in charge of sales
what does he know about leadership he
knows how to sell stuff he doesn't know
anything about leading oh we got echo
charles here he's our best
he's our best mechanic okay great what
are we going to do let's put him in
charge of all the mechanics he's good at
turning the wrench he's not good at
leaders leadership and we just throw him
in there and for some reason
people think that leadership is
something you're just born with or that
you you know how to do in intuitively
and it's just factually not true so what
we encourage and what you're actually
doing is oh echo
you're the best mechanic
we're gonna take you and we're gonna
elevate you into a leadership position
and we're gonna train you how to lead
just like at one point we trained you on
how to turn wrenches and repair this
carburetor we're we're going to we're
going to train you the same way
and you've put a massive amount of
investment into your leadership
and
one of the earlier questions you know
when we started echelon front you know i
get asked well how are we going to
how are we going to know if this works
what are the metrics to know if this
succeeds and i still to this day i just
had this conversation the other day
whatever metric you're running at your
company that means you you are
successful so whether you're trying to
cut the cost to produce or you're trying
to improve your time to produce or
you're trying to grow or whatever metric
you're looking at
if we do our job training your leaders
that metric all those metrics that
you're trying to improve on they are all
going to improve that's what's going to
happen
and and that's where you say hey look we
actually have we do some of these like
you know soft skill surveys now and you
know what do you think your leadership
and that's good too that's good feedback
it's good feedback to say hey the
leadership is now has a better
relationship with the troops that's
great the troops think the leadership is
more in tune with what they're thinking
and what they're saying those are those
are great things to do as well
but
for me where the money for the rubber
meets the road is hey we're trying to
produce this widget in this amount of
time and now we're doing it we're
cutting our costs we're getting it out
our sales people are doing better that's
how we measure leadership success is
what is the success of the company so as
you you invest you get that roi
and that's what i you know that's what i
love about seeing the success of your
company and some of the other companies
that we work with that
we get to see this this incredible
growth and you know i started this whole
thing off saying leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield in
business and life and to look at a
company like yours where you are proving
how that works
and how important it is
and how you can grow things and how you
can have
4 200 employees and i'd love to uh you
know if you were fishing for a
compliment say no but matt it all starts
with you hey it does i'll give you a
compliment it does start with you but
let's face it
you've got employees that haven't seen
you in three months you've got you've
got someone right now making a decision
in a basement 100 percent on
on something that's happening and and
that individual is making the right
decision as a leader on the front lines
he's empowered to do that and you
you couldn't see that if your life
depended on it you couldn't help that
person make that decision
except for the fact that you already
have helped them because you trained him
as a leader they understand the culture
they understand the mission of the
company and when you do that it allows
you to to to drive a company forward
with people at every level leading
making the right decisions and moving in
the same direction strategically it's
the only way to scale
right so you you you just gave that
great example you have we have foreman
right now there's a foreman right now
probably anywhere in the country right
so say he's in kansas city and the
footer is not where he needs to be and
he's laying down what he needs to lay
down he's thinking wow what i got
to do here
he's been empowered he knows the number
one objective take care of the customer
if it costs a few dollars more no factor
if it costs a couple hundred dollars for
more no factor if it costs like a
thousand dollars i'm gonna probably call
my soup to make sure it's cool but that
soup is gonna know no factor go serve
the customer okay but
that mindset is is is part of our
culture and that comes from the
investment that you make in a business
we see it all the time when we buy
businesses you know this this this this
old and i call it lazy the notion of
on-the-job training is lazy
it's lazy
if you if you say to yourself i want to
be world class i want to be good
you don't stick just a guy with a guy
and say go learn from jocko because he's
really good at this
that's lazy small businesses do that
that don't want to grow
if you want to take an institutional
approach to changing an industry and
being the best possible business you can
possibly be
it has to be part of who you are and
that takes time investment and energy
and our kpis at groundworks they've
exploded over the last
four years five years a lot of factors
one key factor one key factor
is investing in leadership training you
can't be a leader in our company unless
you go through it every employee gets a
book
i mean it's it you can't get away from
it now do they read it i don't know but
you can't be a leader and a manager i'm
sorry you can't be a manager you can be
a leader without being a manager you
can't be a manager at groundworks
without going through a course
and that's just who we are now
as you know human beings are human
beings and some people take it better
than others but on average i think our
culture's such that
if you don't live that way you're kind
of weeded out
because there's a complete alignment on
what we are doing as a business not just
our mission of building a great
world-class home services company
but there's a culture internally of
we're going to do it the right way we're
going to care about the men and women
that work here
we call it walking in the light and
living with the servant's heart
and yes we serve the customer but my
leaders we serve each other
and if the the overall goal is to build
a great business where we all win
and we're literally making millionaires
out of men and women that never have
gone to college
we are serving one another
yeah and that's that's the powerful
thing i i gotta share this one pit with
you so fast forward
i'm running out of money
so this was in 19.
um sarah and i you know we put
everything we had in this business uh i
sold i i should so i sold petrochem uh
that company i first started with to to
put back into groundwork so i sold it to
a big-time private equity forum out in
san francisco
uh huge return for for me and the missus
i can't say it publicly but it's
it's way north of five times
over 20.
shipyard staffing i have a great partner
that
his name is jack anthony that i
partnered up with to run that business
for me he absolutely crushed it for us
sold that to of all of all funds the
founders fund
um the most legitimate base vc firm in
the world probably peter thiel and his
team and and all the great investments
some knuckle dragger from ocean view
sold his company
to peter thiel the guy that you know
spacex and paypal all those things right
he started a company called work rise
they are in the oil and gas industry
they bought our little platform to enter
the marine industry in the defense
industry like it's surreal only in
america right so we took every penny
that we had from those things potted
right back and the groundworks but still
wasn't enough
so in 19 uh you know we decided no i i
had outside investors i had some friends
and family you know like folks that that
i've seen and and been friends with no
institutional no big money guys
um
we wanted to continue this mission and i
had worked for four or five years
developing relationships of companies to
buy some big ones and so i finally had
to bite the bullet and and bring on a
financial partner so
um we are fortunate enough i have a
really good friend that is a great
investment banker john nooner for home
services and
i literally saw him on a sunrise service
on easter you'd love this so um
he don't live in vb but you know i have
this little guy logan and
you know we can't take him to church on
easter sunday because he's a madman
he'll run around
so sarah's like hey let's go this
sunrise service he'll just run off and
surf or whatever he does we're still
going to be able to go to church right
so he's running around and we're at this
sunrise service and i look behind me
there's this guy john nooner who i
hadn't seen since college by the way i
was his ra one of the other jobs i had
in college i was an r.a that's terrible
don't judge
that's not a good gig but there there's
this guy john nooner he said hey malone
i've been following your company so this
was in uh this was april of 19 and i say
this is great timing because we need we
need a financial partner so we talked to
13 private equity firms some of the
greatest brands in the world
um
13 offers which again that's surreal
right you build a company and you you
know the names of all these firms right
so it's kind of whoa it's pretty
exciting
we we took it down to three and
ultimately picked one
we picked a group called cortec out of
new york um
um they have a guy that uh is our
chairman a guy named david schneiderick
who is legitimate savage he's more
aggressive than me
but they had great experience with yeti
so they built yeti um they were the
private equity firm behind yeti you know
they took that thing from whatever 40
million to a billion and it's public now
and but they're really good at marketing
and i wanted to transform my business
into a consumer marketing company yes we
do construction yes i have the
horsepower behind the scenes are men and
women that do it with their hands
but how we went in the marketplace with
consumers is being differentiated so
that when
like it's the amazon approach when i'm
coming to your house you said you're
going to get a text it's going to show
where my car is is going to say hey this
guy's going to show up here's what he
looks like so you want to leverage
technology and and really leverage how
we attack the consumer side of our
business and i thought they were good at
that and so we partnered up with them
and then you know covet hit right so
imagine
big investment
covid
everyone is scared at this time right
thankfully at groundworks we were
we were a essential business
which i love so we have these these
shirts that we gave out called the
essentials
but i remember how to get lawyers to
give letters to every driver so as we
went down the road you know if they got
stopped they could put out this letter
and say look we're you know we're
essential so we went to work
and um you know
some parts of the country took cover a
lot different i'll tell you this my guys
was there coveted
like we just got after it now the only
thing we did cancel was the kickoff of
course which uh you for your part of
that but
um we just got after it and
which even crazier so this this this
this group cortec
i had lined up four or five big deals
big companies to buy and uh you know
what we haven't talked about it so the
founders that i bought these companies i
call them the founders made of some of
the best men and women in the country um
we've been very lucky our strategy is we
buy the best brand in a given state we
expand from there opening new offices
um and as you look at the map today you
know we're
we're
we're getting there we're kind of really
southeast midwest mid uh mid-atlantic
we're not west coast we're not texas yet
we're not pacific northeast or new
england
but we're a multi-billion dollar
business just in our current footprint
well i buy these businesses from these
founders who were guys that started with
nothing they built these businesses and
we give them good money for their
businesses great money
many of them most of them reinvest a
little bit into groundwork so they're my
partners
and they they you know they give me
accounts on things like that
so as we're we're building these
businesses uh buying these businesses i
needed to buy a few of these big ones
and uh you know and i didn't see cortec
for many many months i think i've seen
them five times since they've invested
and they've given us a lot of money so
we started on a buying bench and i
bought four of the best brands in the
country
um
we do all our m a in-house so i do all
them and a with my team
cortec allowed us to do that they were
exactly as i thought they would be
part of the reason i picked them going
back to
what we were talking about the
importance of investing in the roi and
leadership development and training
they completely bought off on that
it was most pe firms i should
some pe firms
you know they're looking for every penny
to go the bottom line
never ever once have they said
don't do that or why are you doing that
because it's part of who we are in the
magic sauce like we look we've gone from
30 to 800
across a billion this year
you don't do that without investing in
your people and you can't do on-the-job
training
when you grow that fast so when i say
it's lazy
it's it's lazy in the sense that a small
business can do that because echo and i
can go and he'll teach me how to swing
that wrench and hopefully i'll be a good
mechanic at some point but you can't do
that when you go from 190 people to 4
and um
you know
360 000 in payroll that was that was
that that was payroll when you first
bought the company
i knew my wife and i could cover that
maybe for a month or two if we had to
it's like 20 plus now
it's so it's all surreal for me so um
the importance of investing
and not doing on the job the roi for us
has been i don't know if you could
calculate it candidly because it's built
into everything we do at the company so
it's not like
one specific thing that makes this
company great it's it's thrown into the
the the mindset the culture
it's done into everything that we try to
do and it's a big piece of it as you
know i mean but it's thrown into that so
i've never been asked for my board
um
and i got some i got a legit guy some
legit guys on my board that run public
companies some of the biggest home
services companies they've never said
hey what's this line item here
leadership development they've never
said it because they know it's who we
are because i gave him a book the first
time i met him
i think it was project jocko actually
oh but anyway
the uh when you were talking about how
the the culture gets into the system and
it becomes part of who you are i was
thinking so i was going to officer
candidate school and when you're at
officer candidate school you when you
first show up there it's you know it's a
total indoctrination boot camp style
indoctrination
and you one of the rules they have all
these weird rules one of the rules is
that you can't look at your food so you
sit down to eat you can't look at your
food you can only look straight ahead
and i
remember i was an enlisted guy for my
first eight years
and i'm kind of street smart so i'm
sitting down and i gotta eat and i i
think it was like chicken breast right
so how are you gonna eat a chicken
breast without looking at like how's
that even gonna work right
but also i'm thinking how are they
possibly gonna see if i'd glance down on
my food right
so and and really the people there's
drill instructors so there's marine
corps drill instructors there but
there's also the senior officer
candidates are there so they're so
they're everyone's watching you when you
get into the chow hall for the first
couple well they're they're all time but
the first couple meals where this
happened to me so i'm sitting there i
sit down you know and people are yelling
and screaming
you know don't look at your food look
straight ahead and they call it squaring
your meals also you have to lift your
your food has to go up straight you know
90 degrees up from the ground or from
the plate you have to bring it up
straight and then you know 90 degree
turn into your mouth that's how you
gotta eat they call it squaring your
meals you have to look straight ahead
so as i'm sitting there i'm thinking
they're never gonna be able to tell that
i'm looking my food so i'm just gonna
glance down and get it you know see what
part of the chicken breast i'm about to
eat so i kind of glanced down there and
as soon as
a millisecond after i look down
they're like oh what the hell are you
doing and they get it and i was thinking
myself how did they see that so fast
forward
10 weeks or 11 weeks now i'm one of the
senior people
and i'm standing at the end of the table
and
everyone is staring straight ahead and
it and when one person glances down for
a half a second it's so blatantly
obvious it stands out so much even
though you wouldn't think they could see
you it stands out blatantly obvious and
that's that's what i think happens
inside these companies that we work with
where
you get this attitude of ownership
and when it starts to sink in
anybody on the team that's like well you
know this actually isn't my fault it is
like
so obvious to everyone and eventually it
becomes obvious to yourself eventually
as you're about to say well you know
this isn't really my fault this is
and you can't even get those words out
of your mouth instead you say you know
what what can i do to fix this problem
and it's it's a beautiful thing to see
it's a beautiful thing to see and when
you get that when you get that whole
uh attitude that culture in so deep man
it's really becomes unstoppable it
really does because everyone on the team
now becomes
they're looking to solve problems
they're not looking to blame they're
looking to solve problems you combine
that with decentralized command they
have the authority to solve problems
they know they can fix that problem for
a hundred dollars and you know what's
even
also we you know we're talking about
that example you got something part of
the foundation's a little bit messed up
the attitude he fixed that problem that
problem's probably not happening because
going into that moment when they were
about to set that fixture
that guy says hey you know what if this
isn't good
i i know i'm gonna have to fix it
and i know if it's not good and it's
gonna cost money to fix it i'm gonna
have to call my supervisor and say hey i
messed this up and i you know we're
gonna have to eat this one
so you get that preemptive ownership
where people care more about the job
they want to do it correctly the first
time because they are taking ownership
you know that's the one of the bad
things about extreme ownership is the
first book's all about oh extreme
ownership is in the past it's a mistake
that happened and oh it's my fault which
is good but what's even better than that
i'm not even going to let that mistake
happen and that's what when you when you
have it infused like you have it at your
company people aren't allowing that
those things to happen
and and that's a powerful thing and then
you reinforce that behavior by uh when
they're when they they do make the
decision or there is a mistake you say
no problem yep i'd rather make that
mistake and and not get on the guy for
over correcting right than under
correcting and that feeds on itself too
yeah like if they know okay look i was
empowered to make this decision and i
might have gone overkill and maybe i
laid down more track than i needed to or
maybe this is oh but it's perfect it's a
perfect job
you say okay you probably over built
that but hey bro good good on you you
took care of the customer we call it you
know protecting the patch you got to
protect the brand right so
yeah you know
um
a little bit you know you've glanced on
this a couple times and we've been on
for a little bit but i just want to
before we before we kind of close out
you know one thing you you mentioned a
couple times was you know that the fact
that we we got an average age of welders
at your company your prior company was
54 years old
uh as you know i'm
also in the business of people working
with their hands we've got we've got
people that are manufacturing things in
america that haven't been manufactured
in a long time here uh passing on we
were lucky enough to grab some of that
knowledge you know pete was lucky enough
to grab some of that knowledge from some
of these people that were older than 54
years old you know that we're 65. we've
lost some of those those mentors at
origin that we're passing on first-hand
knowledge of how to do this stuff
is there something that we could do
better as a country um
to help steer people in the right
direction i know i just worked with a
university up in up in indiana called
called ivy ivy tech and they teach
traits that's what they're doing and
you know i had an interesting
conversation with them it's like the the
highest paying job that you can get out
of ivy tech is a elevator repairman
elevator repairman and they make like 80
grand coming out of that school you make
80 grand a year and you got a you got a
a job a career a life
what do how are how are we failing to
educate the the young people in america
that they don't necessarily have to go
to college they don't necessarily have
to get a degree and they don't
necessarily have to look for uh some
kind of a job some kind of a white
collar job
that if you go and you get a trade and
you learn how to do something and you
know i always say this the seal teams
on the enlisted side this is a as blue
collar as it gets i mean that's what
you're doing you're working a machine
gun you're you're building demolition
charges you're
it is and you're a moving company we
always joked about the fact we're always
moving stuff
but
where are we making that mistake how can
we do better in america
well
i think it starts with the perception of
these these jobs right so
if you think about
at home right the parents think now hey
i don't want you to be a plumber i want
you to go to college
well if you look at the data you say
okay look at you got a
was it 1.6 train of college debt and you
have no and i don't want to offend
anybody but this will
you have you're getting you know degrees
and like art history right now no
offense to art history but how many
historians of art do you think there are
in the world that actually operate as
art historians
seven there can't be many right
i mean i don't know but they're they're
not the they're not thousands of these
jobs and what do they pay so
there's this perception how you go to
college is your ticket well
the data would actually show if you if
you if you do a skilled trade at least
my experience so we on a plumbing
division as well look you you have you
have plumbers that easily make 80 96
figures i know welders that worked for
us at shipyard staffing if you're not
making six figures you're not any good
at groundworks you know a good foreman a
good foreman it's 90 to 120 000 a year
now you got to work for it
but think about
think about the perception of
a kid in high school saying hey look i'm
going to go do be electrician now that's
a skill that will they can go anywhere
and do anything and i would argue
economically in today's world their
value is only increasing because there's
fear and fear scarcity does cost it does
drive value
so it's a con it's i believe it's this
this we've been shoved this idea for the
last 20 25 years that you have to go to
college to be successful
that has to change how does that change
it's it's candidly parents i always
believe it starts at home the perception
of hey mike majani and sally or whatever
they need to go to college to be
successful not for everyone i'll tell
you just a quick story at groundworks i
have a uh and you know flint cochran
joined our company used to be with ef
um you know harvard business school
mckenzie he's divisional vice president
of our east coast division our eastern
division he is a counterpart out west
his name is jeffrey martin jeffrey
martin went to moverley high school
that's where he went so this notion of
meritocracy is alive and well at
groundworks and that's just a perfect
example of it if if
if we if we celebrate the men and women
that work with their hands and not
demean them we'll get more of them
and then i think look there has to be
some kind of mindset that that says look
we as a country need to unite around
developing more skilled trades and
pushing it back down to the high school
i don't know if you know but i don't
know any high schools that really have
you know that kind of craft anymore and
it's not for everybody like going to
college is not for everybody but
there are there are there are things we
need to do as a country and i know you
you know this better than me you know
men and women that lead this country
from a legislative standpoint need to
figure out a way to push this agenda
because if they don't now security
national security in my view will be at
risk i only know that from shipyard
staffing
and if you can't repair these boats you
can't build them
and i don't that's not even including
planes and tanks and everything else
they have steel has to be welded
an art history degree is not going to
get you there
so how we solve this as a country look
again my view has to start at home
parents need to think okay
there's still a great livelihood for my
my son or daughter by being being a
skilled tradesman
and we have to as a society celebrate it
like part of the thing at groundworks is
we're celebrating a profession we we
honor you because you work with your
hands you're you're not beneath me
now moses art history majors they end up
slinging you coffee at starbucks right
so you know you look at i mean you say
okay
there's 200 grand down the toilet that
you and i will have to pay for
conversely you go to all the parents out
there if you have kids they can go to a
trade school they come out not in debt
but making money
and they you know they they have a nice
six-figure job ultimately make a ton of
money so it's it it has to start at home
but i think legislative legislatively we
we need to do better at celebrating the
skilled trades and put a concerted
effort on building it just like you
would build a military yeah it's it's
really what we're building
and then
uh
like you mentioned uh i'm in the
manufacturing business as well doing it
here in america
beautiful um
you guys are are you
how much are you able to
keep your manufacturing in america it's
all in america so i didn't mention this
but we're we're vertically integrated as
you know we have we have our software
business but we make our own uh steel
products as well so
i get too technical because you fall
asleep but you know when we when we
secure foundations we get to the footer
we put brackets on we drive steel to
support the foundations of a home
well all that steel
we've patented our own products and we
we actually make it in a 120 000 square
foot facility in rosewood south carolina
you know we have we have lasers and and
machines and you know 40 guys out there
getting after it so that's not imported
steel we do it right here in america
you know all our pumps and dehu's also
made here in america it's it's our
little part to serve the countries if
you can do it you should do it and
again we're not big manufacturers like
you guys but
if you're going to serve the country in
any little way you need to serve the
country and part of way of serving the
country is making it here in america i
think we saw with pandemic and
what's going on in china and the rest of
the world hey man
it'd be nice to have a supply chain from
from some south carolina versus
from india that's sitting off the coast
here right now in a boat i i've always
i'm a very lucky person in in a lot of
different ways but certainly uh
the luck
the luck of being kind of obsessed with
building stuff in america and having
that supply chain up and you know pete
and the rest of the team at origin
good you know
we when covid hit we were kind of
looking around look we were
it was horrible and you know people are
losing their jobs it was horrible but we
were kind of looking around like nodding
our head going we were on the right path
and we're not worried about we're not we
don't have we don't have containers
sitting off the coast of wherever
waiting to
waiting to get here we have our supply
chain it's an american supply chain and
then like you said
we're employing americans and we got
people that are are building this
country and and taking these skills you
know had a conversation with someone
who's talking about
you know people people not being fit for
the military right i'm sure you've seen
articles like that you know they say
that the kids are spending so much time
on video games or whatever that they
won't even be
fit to
join the military you know and i kind of
said well who's going to fight the wars
if a war comes well this is a very
similar thing right who's going to weld
the ships who's going to manufacture the
weapons who's going to actually have the
skills to do that
and
yeah this uh the idea
i think you mentioned that
who's going to uh technical schools
nowadays you know it's just
i don't even know
like the high school where my kids went
they they don't they are trying now to
reopen the the the automotive you know
repair section when i went to high
school all the kids were working on cars
it was part of you know everyone was
building their own car and and doing
that and then a lot of them went on to
do that for for a living
where's that where who's going to do
this stuff now if we don't refocus
america on
on the the skills that we need as a
nation to be self-sufficient
could not agree more
just don't need to say more could not
agree more and
if it's not done jakka there would be
real ramifications to it right i mean
it's it's a silent killer at the moment
because it's getting done
people don't even know it
but
again average age
and i've read that average age of you
and manufacturing job in the country is
average age yeah
i got to throw one more thing out there
because i've i've
just just for anyone that's 18 19 20 22
years old whenever you are
a lot of times i i talk to people and
they say well you know i don't want to
be doing that kind of physical labor my
whole life well i'm going to tell you
right now
if you go if you become an electrician
or you become a plumber
you're not going to do that if you're if
you're smart and you're hard-working and
you really get after it and you have the
intention
of elevating in that environment
you'll absolutely do it i mean who's the
guy you were talking about that's a high
high school graduate
uh that's right jeffrey martin so yeah
so jeffrey martin is he is he right now
how old is jeffrey martin he's 32 32.
his dad owned the business he started
so he was slinging steel at like 14 or
15 right so his experience level is
crazy right so
uh but he did 20 years of sling and
steel
he's not in a crawl space anymore no no
and so my point is that and i've got
i've got multiple friends like this that
started off they were an electrician
and they were an electrician for four
years six years and all of a sudden they
got put in charge of two electricians
and then they got put in charge of four
electricians then they went and said you
know what if i'm gonna be running four
electricians i might as well just have
my own business that's right and they
start their own businesses and now they
have 28 electricians working for me and
you can go in any one of these trades if
you have the mindset and you want to
learn and you want to grow and you want
to you want to take a little extra time
to understand the financial part of it
if you have that mindset you can run you
can run any kind of business that you
want so don't think when i'm sitting
here or matt's sitting here saying hey
we need people that are gonna know how
to weld we do but this doesn't mean
you're gonna be necessarily welding
until you're 62 years old you can if you
want to that's correct but if your goal
is to
is to grow out of that role you'll have
the experience to do it you'll have the
money to do it and you will definitely
in this country have the opportunity to
do it that's what america provides 100
the notion that by the way you can't be
educated
by not going to college
is false the notion is you go to college
you get educated
you can be educated by doing your craft
and still learning and being a learned
adult you just have to take the time to
do it you'd have to read the books you
have to study on your own there's
the notion that these some things 100
correlated or wrong that's part of the
mindset is i know a lot of very smart
foreman
a lot of very smart form you join our
company you start as an installer takes
you a year to get to foreman
if you're any good then after that a
couple years you can move to super and
then production manager and then
ultimately to general manager then
ultimately to regional manager and then
divisional and then hopefully one day
ceo but the point is you still have to
take and do the work
do the work of growing your mind
investing in yourself and you don't have
to have a sheepskin to say it you just
have to have the mindset to go learn
and and the notion the two are
separated is a fallacy in my opinion and
it's it's just all you know he you
mentioned uh
peter thiel right peter thiel like he's
he's hiring people and he's been doing
that he doesn't care if he went to
college or not and he's running a
freaking you know he's running a giant
uh giant company that's that's moving
money billions of dollars look at all
these founders uh the big founders the
big name founders as you see out there
musk and theo and
uh
zuck and all these guys they don't have
a degree
i call him zuck echo like i know him
yeah
bro
uh awesome stuff probably a good place
we get to the so let's just look where
we at right now groundworks what's the
what's the future
well i think ultimately
we want to continue the mission of
course expand i look at i think
ultimately this is a public company i
think we're getting to the point we're
going to be so big you're going to need
the capital to ultimately go public
i think right now if you think about our
business we are in the water management
displacement business
but you know we operate with an mps um
over 70 nps's net promoter score it's
how you measure your performance with
consumers
you know we're going to move into other
home services lines we we believe our
mindset
and our ability to service the customer
we think there are other lines that we
can get into to further expand our
business
you know gutters and um plumbing and
other things i think we're just
beginning to build this business and so
ultimately i think groundworks will be
my passion will be that this this is a
business that lasts 100 years
that
a business that celebrates again men and
women that work with their hands they
can go for a not a job but for a
profession
that's built with a with a common sense
of respect and dignity where it's a true
meritocracy that doesn't matter where
you come from or what degree you have
that you can come to a company like
groundworks and and make it to the very
top
um that so that's where we're going
that's where we're going do i have look
you heard my career it's a little bumpy
and and uh
it's you know my buddies call me the
forrest gump of finance and some of
these stories like that bro that can't
be true i swear it's all true
um but i don't know i just know if we
build something great you invest in
people
you surround yourself with really smart
people uh and you and you you push them
to grow and be better
you can do anything okay i think that's
that's where we're going and if i could
just make one final comment
um
as you
as you think about your listeners as you
think about kind of how we started
i would just say this if if you truly
sitting there and you want to be in
business you want to be an entrepreneur
and you you want to invest in yourself
and you believe that that ultimately
you get the life you give yourself
that
you can do it you can do it if you
put in the time you have the discipline
you're obsessed about whatever it is
i hope you know the dialogue and you've
gathered from our conversation that you
you in this country
if you can do it and a guy like me
you know knuckle dragger from ocean view
you know sitting down here with the
you know
jocko and his team and the the best
podcast in the country and
um the folks i've been able to to to
meet in my career
but most importantly you can you can
really do the impossible
if you really just go after it and
um
that's that's i hope your listeners take
away is that anything is possible it
truly is you just you just gotta go do
it and it's not easy oh no and there's
gonna be nights and your wife's gonna
look at you and say don't send that
email and you're gonna have to get up
and you're gonna take risks and you're
gonna do things and you're not gonna win
every time
and and that's when it counts that's
what when you say you got to keep going
that's when it counts characters defined
by hardship right that's the only way to
get better looking i'm not a ceo i'll
never serve but i'm sure that's how you
guys look at it but business
business is no different
and you know that you're an entrepreneur
the ups and downs characters really you
you learn more on failure than you do on
victory and
and the character is defined by the
things that make you a better person and
a better business person you know we we
believe that at groundwork we talk about
walking in the light the goal is to make
everyone a better human
and if you're a better human you're
better professional and
you know i joked about the catholic
thing to begin with the morality that uh
kind of instilled
but
you can do the impossible if you do walk
in the light you care about others you
lead with a servant heart
you make the mistakes you do you you
make the investments you take the risks
you get up every day even if it's off
the ground and you do it again
if i can do it
anyone can do it
that's america
echo charles any questions yeah you have
watched shark tank yes sir is that your
jam that's not my gym you know it's
funny
i actually tell sarah say hey look
they're stealing these companies from
these people you know that the
valuations they're giving these guys
interesting yeah so if you and if you
ever have an idea don't go on shark tank
you come to see you okay yes sir i
understand baby okay all right oh you
also said uh we're kind of in passing
you mentioned
lifestyle business you said it was a
lifestyle business and you kind of what
does that mean lifestyle business so
there are a lot of owners out there that
don't reinvest in their business they
they take money out of the business to
you know buy a house or second house or
boat or
you know that we call those lifestyle
businesses and
they're nice lifestyle business but
there's no long-term viability and
health for those things they'll they'll
die as soon as that that owner dies so
what like kind of almost like they have
the business just so they can make money
for their lifestyle correctly as opposed
to
reinvesting every penny they have to
make it grow and to build it et cetera
um you see a lot of it looks a lot of
small businesses are lifestyle business
and there's nothing wrong with that
but when you can when we compete with
lifestyle businesses you can imagine
it's it's ugly no
not much competition i understand cool
good good to see you right on well matt
thanks for coming on thanks for sharing
some of these lessons um
and most important thanks for what
you're doing today i mean uh you can
probably hear when i talk about this and
i talk about all the time and i live it
too
the fact that you're
building a company that is
well it first of all it's providing a
much needed service right i mean like
you said it's the american dream to have
a house it's not american dream to have
a house with a basement full of water
uh but but you not only provide that
service but
you know you you give ownership to your
workforce and they get a skill and they
get a career
uh it's just powerful and that that
helps
that is that is what drives the american
economy that's what does it and that
attitude
that attitude that work ethic that's the
american culture
and and look the american culture might
get might get pushed around a little bit
it might get it might get some layers
put on it by various things that are
going on in the world but the american
culture
of hard work the culture of
entrepreneurship
and the culture that
supersedes all those
is the culture of taking care of your
family taking care of your friends
taking care of your community taking
care of your people
that's the american way and that's how
you win and thank you for being an
example of making that happen
thank you sir
and with that mr matt malone has left
the building
so
echo charles yes sir
did you get a little bit of the
uh beyond the shark tank on that because
for you i think i think i think in your
mind business is kind of like shark tank
actually you're kind of right no i think
like legit yeah
yeah well
like anything you know you have kind of
what's in front of your face and that
goes through like your life i guess when
you kind of go through it
and then every once in a while you get
reminded that there's this bigger game
being played
or even a smaller game being played that
plays a bigger role in your life you
know like that kind of stuff
and this is like one of those reminders
where he's over here talking about like
he early on in the pa in
this episode he used he just mentioned
like derivatives oh i didn't want to do
that like kind of like it was just this
foregone everyone knows that kind of a
tone
and
a lot of these terms that he was using
was like wait
and i was going to interrupt but you
know in the spirit of keeping the flow i
didn't um
where i wanted to be like wait what's
that wait what's that wait what's that
because it would tell a clear story for
us
who are not in that big game
to understand a little bit more about
how it works yeah
yeah well the i guess
the
trying to get like you said trying to
get to the kind of ultimate position
where he got to where he is now i think
was cool uh and i think that's and plus
maybe i was just like going yeah
derivatives you know right yeah it was
clearly probably not the best uh person
to filter some of that stuff out or to
inquire about it but what's interesting
to uh well the the the
each one like each one of those things
is its own world right and what'd you
what were you calling it next level what
were you saying big game no play there's
different games man yeah and then
there's games
within the games but then more
importantly to remember you're in
there's a game that's bigger than the
game you're in yeah and that's what's
always happening yeah and you got to be
careful
in life that you don't get trapped in
the game
and think that you won that game because
there's a bigger game going on yes you
need to watch out for it now listen
here's the thing
you could never
very few people are just going to win
every game yeah like all the games the
big game right what do you got to do
what's the winning the biggest game is
it elon musk and he won like the big
game
it could be but also there's some people
that don't care about any of that yeah
so it's important to remember that do
you care about the game that someone
else is playing
this is comes back this whole
discussion we had one time
where i was i compared basketball and
soccer right like someone's playing
soccer they're the best soccer player in
the world in their whole season they
score four goals
and they're the best at that game
meanwhile someone plays basketball they
score four goals in the first minute
and in the season they play they score
thousand points
so what game are you playing yeah and
you got to be careful because you might
be
i've known plenty of people in my day
and i'm sure you have too that worked
really really really hard and won the
game that they were playing and were
winning that game
but it
but it was limited yeah you know they
weren't really barely even getting on
the board yeah so you want to make sure
that you're playing a game that you can
win and then you also at a certain point
you say look i don't really care about
that next level game yeah i don't i
don't care about that i don't need
to win the game above my game and the
game above that game right i don't care
about those games because
basically the games we're talking about
right now are all business financial
earning games yeah because what you know
you got a game that you're playing to
win with your family to win with your
legacy to pass on good behaviors to your
children to help your community to build
good relationships like there's that too
your health your health
right so we're gonna abandon those
things so
i think it's important to and i think i
think matt spent quite a bit of time
doing that playing a game and not
necessarily winning a game but saying i
don't even want to play that game yeah
oh let me try this other game i don't
like that game oh let me try another
game i don't really like that game and
finally figured out oh here's a game
that i like i actually want to be an
operator that makes stuff happen i want
to interact with people i mean
look there's some people that don't want
to interact with other humans
leadership is something they don't even
want to do
they just want to be in charge of like
their computer screen you know that's
cool
so
yeah and the money part of things is a
real easy one to kind of gravitate to as
far as your attention and like maybe
even a lot of time your value system
because like like obviously guys like
matt where that's they're interested in
that part of things you know the fight
he wanted to be an investment banker and
you know that's not like a rare thing or
nothing necessarily but bro i'll tell
you right now
i never even
considered thinking about
even that whole industry and i'm sure a
lot of people like that too it's like
hey what do you want to be when you grow
up investment banker's not part of that
thing
but investment banking isn't or uh
what's involved in investment banking is
a very specific type of thing that
people like mata like that's part of
their interests like man it has to do
with something like that
so
when you see the results of a successful
guy who's into that kind of stuff it's
easy to be like oh yeah he's winning a
bigger quote-unquote bigger game than me
but i feel like
the bigger game that i'm talking about
is the game that's like like if you were
to structure your life
then
what did he say what do you do this
scale that's when you guys use right
business guys
scale it it's like you can make this
right but to scale it means you're above
maybe 10 people making that same thing
10 times the amount right and you scale
it a lot of times
that scale game
that's the part we all miss
but investment banking is kind of like
this part of it anyway given what i
understand which is not that much
part of what would drive maybe interest
in that industry
is the same stuff that's going to draw
your interest towards things like being
able to scale x y z thing yeah because
the interest isn't on the xyz thing it's
about the scaling part of it see what
i'm seeing yeah
yeah
it's good stuff it is interesting well
what i was going to say is that
the also
like for instance
at
origin right we're making jeans we could
make more money making jeans in china
right so we could
we could allegedly win a certain part of
the game but we're playing by other
rules and we're not winning the game
that we want to win we want to win the
game bringing back american
manufacturing so
you gotta
it's not it's quite so cut and dry and
the other thing i was thinking about
when you just talk about raw money
what are people going to use that money
for a lot if you think about like an end
game is you're going to use that money
to buy time oh now i don't have to work
anymore i can do whatever i want
well how much
how much time did you invest into
getting the money so that you could buy
time
so you got to run that game you got
gotta run those numbers in your head
because if you're investing all your
time into in to make money so that you
can buy your time back you might be
losing you know unless you figure out a
way to scale it which is what you were
just talking about unless you figured
out a way to scale it you're gonna have
a hard time doing that
so that's why it's important in my
opinion to be doing something that you
really love doing yeah you know i i
never even ever thought i was working
in while i was in the navy probably let
me rephrase that
i i was very seldom considering what i
was doing work
just didn't seem like work ever
like
just didn't seem like work so that's a
really good life you know i had i didn't
need money to buy time because i had all
the time in the world because i was
doing exactly what i wanted to all the
time yeah that makes sense so
so that's good stuff
all right um hey if you want to
invest in your health
get yourself some stuff some healthy
things to put in your body oh yeah you
know what i'm saying yeah you noticed
you know when we offered matt
some
go yeah what flavor he chose yeah i am a
clean energy champion oh that's
undisputed that's right factually yeah
you know it's a good deal either way we
did notice matt chose it and you know it
is what it is but good news either way
whatever flavor you pick
boom you got some clean energy healthy
energy if you will which is not a common
thing you want to talk about uncommon
yep it's true these other
you know drinks
they
the funny thing is there's no there's
there's like there's no truth in
advertising
they don't say they don't say hey we're
we're
not that good for you
but we'll give you like an hour and a
half of like hype
you don't say that
they can throw they can throw they can
actually use the term clean energy yeah
and you could they could be feeding you
arsenic yeah they don't care yeah
because because there's water in it and
water's clean yeah water is clean yeah
so that's the thing
from three mile island yeah it depends
the
so there's there's a difference between
line and then not telling the truth you
know how there's like half truths and
all this stuff but at the end of the day
it comes from like deception right if
it's like are you being deceptive so my
wife used to and i used to pull this one
me and my wife my girlfriend at the time
started dating she would be like oh
she's like hey you're lying i'm like no
no i'm not lying about this or whatever
and she'll be like no you're being
misleading and i was like
i can't deny that part of it because you
know you know like you know when you're
hiding something on purpose
or you're adding something making it
look bigger than it is on purpose it's
like you're misleading it's the same as
lying bro
that's what these energy drink companies
do there yeah they do so don't fall for
that don't misleading lies sometimes i
see them and i just want to
tell the truth about what they're
actually doing
um but we we are telling the truth about
ours it's good for you it's true it's
good for you
it's good for you get yourself some of
that jackalful.com
uh get it at wawa get that vitamin shop
we're rolling out a bunch of other
stores school
continual growth which is pretty cool
we're scaling scaling man all day for
good reason too because you do want to
stay capable and healthy of course
health is a game that we're playing it's
a game that's the one game you can't
afford to lose you cannot afford to lose
but here's the thing a lot of people are
losing that game and we don't even
realize it why because like you said you
might he might some people focus on the
wrong game
so a lot of times this whole thing
gotta focus on that one
stay in the winner's circle so yeah we
got the stuff for your joints some
protein
vitamin d for your immunity all kinds of
stuff yeah originusa.com that's where
you get it no that's where you get jiu
jitsu stuff actually includes
jackalful.com that's my battery yeah
look at you jacofuel.com that's where
you can get the supplementation stuff
origin usa is where you can get the
american made from beginning to end
american-made
clothing they got some good hoodies on
there by the way
i just used the heavy where are you
snowboarding big bear
all day legit nope how was that how was
the snow held up it was right after a
storm so oh
anyway speaking of powerpile
jockofstore.com
uh jackalstar.com is where you can get
your discipline equals freedom stuff
your gear your apparel from there if you
want to represent while you're on this
path playing the game of health and
capability and strength and endurance by
the way
i feel like we don't talk about
endurance as much as we could get on the
mats man you're on the mat that
endurance shows up real quick
that freaking hardcore guard passing
game that's a fatiguing game like you
got to be you got to be metabolically
conditioned in the modern day
to to pass guard yes it's a new game
well you oh i agree with you not 100 110
percent because you in the guard passing
game if they're active we'll call it an
active and or aggressive guard passing
game you can be the giver or the
receiver if you're defending that same
game
right you better have your conditioning
that's what i'm saying because you have
to think about it you are correct you
are correct but yes if you're oh you
know you want to represent
a pair of wise when you're on this path
jackalstore.com so you can get the stuff
short locker is a subscription it's
called shirt locker it's a subscription
situation where you get a new shirt
different design creative design every
month
what
they are creative you created some of
the designs
somebody said we we have one that says
everybody must get stoned yeah
which is based on the stoner 63 machine
gun that the seals carried in nom yeah
and i saw a twitter
feedback
someone said i can't wear this because
it's you know has to do with smoking
marijuana you know i was like no it
doesn't have anything to do here well i
guess it does have a
there's a dual meaning so here that's
not how we mean it
here's how the shirt means it in my view
tell me what you think about this so and
i told someone this too
uh
i forget who i told but okay so you got
everyone must get stoned right wasn't
there like a marijuana issue
in vietnam there was like there was guys
smoking or whatever okay so
yeah so there's like when you say there
there's a dual message there right so it
depends on who you are everyone must get
stoned
like edit surface values like oh what
everyone must get so everyone must smoke
weed
or
from a warrior perspective or whatever
everyone must get stoned you see i'm
saying yeah so it's like a dual meme
that's what i'm saying it's so legit
yeah i think exactly this guy
wasn't down for the cause kind of
basically if you see it and and just to
repeat the story
i heard from a vietnam guy that he got
his weapon from the armory
after someone else had used his weapon
and nom he like took whatever year off
went back to get his weapon
and he got went to get his stoner 63 and
on the butt stock someone had written
everybody must get stoned and if that's
not badass come on dude yeah another
layer yeah
that's the deal so if you want to get
those kind of cool
shirts with layers yep go there sure
locker choco store
also subscribe
if you haven't you want to leave a
review if you're in the mood to leave a
review there is that option leave a
review you ever see a review i said i
reviewed the other day said
we came for jocko we stayed for echo
yeah okay all right you think that being
nice or you think that's true
i'd say they both have their problem
equal probability to be honest with you
um either way hey i'll take it thank you
for saying that
for feeling that really uh
jockowunderground.com come and check
that out eight dollars and 18 cents a
month we got on a little platform that
in case things go sideways we'll still
be here um if you can't afford it then
email assistance at
jacounderground.com we got a youtube
channel
jocko's podcast we got origin usa check
out that youtube channel psychological
warfare we've got all that stuff going
on flipside canvas dakota meyer by the
way he's i don't even know when this
podcast is coming out but he's in
ukraine right now
just just being dakota god bless him
uh if you want to support his company
while he's over in ukraine like saving
people by the way he saves people in
america too he's a firefighter and he's
a medal of honor recipient in case you
weren't aware of that he's got a company
here in america it's called
flipsidecanvas.com go and check that out
buy some cool stuff to hang on your wall
i've written a bunch of books you can
read those we got echelon front you
heard me talk about it today that's uh
you know matt and and groundworks is a
one
case study of what we do with businesses
how we help them align their leadership
and help them learn how to lead and help
them develop leaders so if you want to
check that out go to echelonfront.com
and part of what we're doing there is
an online training platform you know
like you heard matt today say he's got 4
200 employees
4 200 workers 4 200 owners
this is
not the biggest company we work with we
work with companies that have thirty
thousand fifty thousand a hundred and
fifty thousand employees globally so
originally we created a online training
platform for that
we decided to open it up to everyone
it's got courses you can take it's got
live interactions go to
extremeownership.com if you want to
check that out
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families you want to you want to
get involved in an awesome charity
organization check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got an awesome
organization really truly helps veterans
and their families go to america's
mighty mightywarriors.org
if you want to help out
and also check out horses
and also check out heroes and horses
dot com
so micah fink just up there
he's out in the bush right now by the
way
going on whatever 78 day expedition on
horseback
cold water bass in the morning resetting
people's brains bro and their hearts how
you like that and their souls
micah you can use that if you want you
can use my verbage that i just
just made up uh as far as echo and i go
we are we are
both on social media
we're there we're not getting sucked up
in the algorithm though so watch
yourself if you go in there echoes
adequate charles i'm at taco willing
thanks to matt malone for coming here
today sharing his lessons and thanks to
all the workers out there across the
land
the tradesmen
the skilled laborers the men and women
that toil every day to build to
construct to fabricate to repair to
manufacture
we know
that that is the strength of america
that's what builds america so thank you
to the american worker thank you for
what you do and thanks to all the
military personnel out there
who work their craft
to keep america free so that the workers
can work and also thanks for the work
done by our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers
border patrol secret service
and all first responders who protect us
here at home and to everyone else out
there there is opportunity
but it's not going to knock on your door
in fact it's not really even going to
let you know it's around like the lights
are off that's what's happening it's not
easy to find you got to work for it you
got to kick in some doors and there's
going to be struggles along the way and
you'll have ups and downs
but
if you get started and you can start in
any position
this is america you can start anywhere
but if you're willing to work hard and
you don't give up you can find that
opportunity and you can turn that
opportunity
into
a reality
so go out there
and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko